JavaScript gives us specific
capabilities to perform any website
related task including design the front
end and working on the back end this is
just one of the numerous factors
contributing to javascript's appeal in
2022 research shows that JavaScript
stands among the world's top 10 most
widely used programming languages
if you want to know about the importance
of JavaScript try disabling it on your
browser and your web pages will not work
properly in fact sites like Facebook
Google Netflix and YouTube will not work
without JavaScript so hello everyone and
welcome to the simple YouTube channel I
hope you guys are doing well today we
will be taking you through the
JavaScript full course we will cover
everything in this video from Basics to
advanced level topics don't worry if
you're a newbie or an advanced level
developer this video will help you in
different aspects
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos
so if you are a tech Deacon of
continuous hunt for the latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so let's go through the agenda for this
tutorial we'll start this video by
understanding what JavaScript is where
we will see how JavaScript came into
existence we'll also go through the
different reasons to learn JavaScript
following that we will cover basic
JavaScript topics like document object
model in JavaScript and vs code
installation
will also create a hello world program
in JavaScript
next we will cover the fundamentals of
JavaScript including JavaScript
statements comments variables data types
type conversions and operators in
JavaScript then we will move on and
cover topics like control statements and
Loops in JavaScript
both topics have the outmost importance
when it comes to any programming
language once we are done with the basic
topic we will move ahead and cover the
intermediate level JavaScript topics
like JavaScript functions strings and
arrays following that we will cover
important topics like objects prototypal
inheritance and many more such topics
once we are done with the basic and
intermediate level topics we will move
on to some advanced level topics like
callback functions promises Arrow
functions regular expression and formal
Edition in JavaScript
we'll work on certain projects to end
this video we'll create a verbal game
and a functional website it is rightly
said that you can Master a programming
language just by programming in it I
hope you guys are ready to learn
something new
so without any further Ado let's start
the first topic for the day JavaScript
was developed in the year 1995 by a
person named Brendan Ike Brendan was
working for Netscape Communications
while he developed JavaScript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
JavaScript initially it was mocha which
was later changed to livescript and then
it finally became JavaScript the start
of JavaScript wasn't that good as so
many developers who were using Java at
that time
they considered JavaScript as a language
for designers and known Engineers no one
ever knew that this small side scripting
language would have a great future today
more than 90 percent of the websites out
there they are using JavaScript somehow
many of you guys gets confused with Java
and JavaScript let me clear it for you
that both Java and JavaScript they are
different languages they have almost
nothing in common many people say that
JavaScript was named after Java as a
part of a marketing strategy to gain
wider acceptance and recognition in 1995
Java was a buzzword when JavaScript was
developed that's why they renamed
JavaScript after Java let's move on to
what is Javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
Amazon the home page of Amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of JavaScript
in Layman language JavaScript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when JavaScript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
JavaScript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
Android or in iOS but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for Android we have to learn Java
and XML and Swift We have to learn for
iOS but with the help of JavaScript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
Tech giants like Google PayPal Amazon
and YouTube they are using JavaScript
these days the evolution of JavaScript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
Gmail let's suppose so Gmail is a single
page website which looks more like
desktop software than a website so Gmail
is based on angular.js it is a popular
framework by Google which is free of
cost and it is totally based on
JavaScript now let's go over some of the
features of JavaScript these features
are actually why it is considered that
using JavaScript is advantages over
other languages
so let's start some of these points
JavaScript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like C plus plus and Java they
need a compiler to work but with
JavaScript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly next up is
lightweighted Javascript can provide
programming facility to some extent in
JavaScript you don't need to specify any
data type or return type which helps in
making development more quicker that's
why it is known as light weighted
JavaScript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
JavaScript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well
there is a way to validate the user's
Data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
JavaScript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data JavaScript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
JavaScript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider JavaScript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept it does support
other features of object oriented
programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
JavaScript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions JavaScript differentiates
between capital and lower case letters
we have to keep this in mind while
programming
now I will quickly go over some of the
JavaScript applications where JavaScript
is currently being implemented first one
that comes to every person's mind is web
development it was also the main motive
behind developing JavaScript we have
Technologies like angular we have
node.js we can create beautiful web
pages also JavaScript can be used along
with HTML and CSS to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
JavaScript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
JavaScript can take over traditional
Android and iOS app one of the most
important and unique application of
JavaScript is in smart watches the
bangle.js is an open sourced Smartwatch
powered by JavaScript Gordon Williams
the man who is currently working on this
project it is said that this new open
sourced stack built around JavaScript
will replace the onboard firmware soon
the next application of JavaScript is
client-side validation as we discussed
earlier JavaScript is used to validate
the user data whether the user's input
is correct or Not by cross checking it
with the given condition like the user
wants to enter in your website and you
want it to be a user with at the rate
gmail.com in his email ID so you will
give that condition to JavaScript and it
will cross check it with the user's
information like when the user will try
to enter in your website it will check
that if at the rate gmail.com is there
or not in the user's email ID
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
JavaScript is game development
JavaScript can be used to make fully
fledged 2D or 3D games using different
libraries although most JavaScript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
JavaScript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
JavaScript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smooth let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use JavaScript the
first one is the basic knowledge of HTML
and CSS to use JavaScript along with
HTML and CSS you first need to know how
HTML and CSS Works see HTML is used to
create the structure of a web page while
CSS is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with JavaScript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn JavaScript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS it's better to have a web
browser that supports JavaScript like
Google Chrome or Mozilla Firefox or you
can use Safari as well if you are using
a MacBook you will need an operating
system like Windows Linux or Mac
operating system to learn JavaScript a
computer with minimum 512 MB of ram
would be enough for you to start
learning JavaScript but I will recommend
you a computer with 1GB of Ram or 4GB of
RAM for a better experience you can use
any text editor you have notepad which
is free and is already available for
Windows if you don't want to use notepad
you can use other free softwares like
sublime or you can use visual code in
this particular course we will be using
visual code and I'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
JavaScript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
JavaScript let's start this video with
some facts about JavaScript
JavaScript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the Market at that time just
like Java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser JavaScript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of JavaScript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend JavaScript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
JavaScript means almost every website
out there is using JavaScript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack Overflow
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
Overflow states that JavaScript is the
most popular programming language used
by the Developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
JavaScript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks JavaScript is constantly
growing and is a well-paid job
JavaScript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
JavaScript provides wide range of usage
as well let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to design a
website like Gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design UI
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful JavaScript
Frameworks next up is constant truth one
of the main reasons behind one should
learn JavaScript JavaScript is one of
the fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
Mobile Market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is Possible only with the help of
JavaScript that's why JavaScript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that JavaScript will go down shortly
the developers working in JavaScript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn JavaScript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
JavaScript jobs section
JavaScript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages like Java Python and PHP
JavaScript provides easy entry points to
the world of programming the best thing
about JavaScript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
JavaScript which means you can start
coding right away JavaScript has the
largest community among all the
programming languages out there
Community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is the more
help you would be likely to get
currently JavaScript has the biggest
stack Overflow Community it has
overtaken Java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
Pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn JavaScript by knowing
JavaScript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
backend you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis this is nothing you can't do
with JavaScript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning JavaScript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in USA and in India
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client-side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in India but if you are a full
stack developer in US you can earn up to
hundred thousand dollars per annum which
is a huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a JavaScript
developer works on the front end and
sometimes backend also
a JavaScript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a JS developer in US
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to Indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a UI is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a UI ux designer earns in India is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document Dom defines the whole HTML
document in a hierarchical form to make
it understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes whether it
be elements or text or anything stored
in the document the entire page content
can be accessed or manipulated by
JavaScript Dom is not used with
JavaScript only other languages like
python also uses dom dom was designed to
be used independently to begin with dom
there is nothing special you have to do
different browsers have different
implementation of the document object
model every browser uses Dom to make the
web page of the document accessible by
JavaScript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example I believe you guys have the
basic knowledge of HTML and CSS a
prerequisite for this course let's start
things off with a basic HTML example
here we have a code that consists tags
like HTML head body heading tag Etc we
have the HTML tag here the opening HTML
tag and the closing HTML tag inside the
HTML tag we have the head tag which
contains the documents header part
inside the head tag there is a title tag
that contains the title of the web page
then comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with IDs as
div 1 and div2 a div tag defines a
particular section in the HTML document
the ID used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it CSS and JavaScript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it let us first
see the output of this code before going
to the document object model of this
whole document so guys this is the
output of the previous code we just came
through here we can see the title of the
web page as well as heading after it
there were two different div tags used
in the code here is the output of both
the div tags the question here is where
are those ID and class attributes seen
in the output the answer to this
question is there's nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our CSS file or through
JavaScript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the HTML cool but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the doll next starting from the HTML
tag and covering all the other tags like
head title body and few more the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format
JavaScript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects JavaScript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
function for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
The Heading tag with JavaScript you can
also work on the style of this text with
the help of JavaScript as well
JavaScript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the Dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
node the element node consists of all
the tags used in HTML document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
HTML document by now I hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
JavaScript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply it can also be accessed with
the help of JavaScript it is the value
of that particular element before
installing vs code let's discuss a few
things about what is an IDE
so IDE stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshops makes it easier for us
to edit photos in the same way IDE makes
it easier for a programmer to write code
if you want to write code IDE will help
you write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of Ides present in
the market today we have Sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is a open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
Mac it is available for Linux and
windows as well I think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to Google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from their official website click on
that and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download this
table version from here only or if you
want to download it for you according to
your PC's specifications you can click
on the download button present at the
top right corner of your screen here you
can see that vs code is available for
different platforms it is available for
Windows for Linux and for Mac as well
you can download it from here as well so
if you want to download this for Windows
you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
condition you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it this window will open where
you have to select the location you want
your vs code to locate
any ID you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want but for now I'll be
leaving it as it is and I'll click on
next now this will open and you will
click next from here now it will ask you
some questions like if you want to
create a desktop icon or not select all
of them and click on next now click on
install and it will install vs code for
you sit back and relax it will take time
so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is Explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice so here
in my PC I'll go to work and I'll
take JavaScript as my folder I'll select
it and see it will open the folder and I
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and I have a few more programs like this
and this you can open any program from
that folder by using this Explorer
option you can open any program present
in that folder so basically what it does
any program you make in Visual Studio
code you will save it in this folder
only so it will be easy for you to open
any program anytime next up we have the
search button to find any keyword or
word present in your code whatever you
write here it will show you where it is
present in your code or in your document
so let's suppose I write here simply
learn C it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press Ctrl F from your
keyboard and write anything here like
it's written simply linear press enter
and it will show you the result the
third option here is for Version Control
if you want to use any Version Control
like you want to use git vs code has
very good integration with Git the next
button here is for debug or it will run
your program once you are done with
writing the code click here and run and
debug just open it with chrome you have
a shortcut for this as well press F5
from your keyboard and it will do the
same the next button here is for
extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
Community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is HTML CSS support just click
on the search button write HTML CSS
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few modes you have to
install JavaScript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way I'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
is
close it create a new file we will name
it as new DOT HTML
so it's new DOT HTML here one thing you
have to keep in mind while saving a file
make sure to save that file with DOT
HTML extension here we are about to
start writing our first program so just
write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic HTML code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code Studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as I have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with JavaScript enabled in it so
if you are using Google Chrome it's
quite easy to enable JavaScript let me
take you through open Google Chrome go
to settings and just write JavaScript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
JavaScript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so I'm
good to go once you have downloaded the
editor and you are done with the
environment setup and all you can start
writing the program so let's go to es
code we will open a new file here and
save it with the name let's open a new
file and we will save it with name
first dot HTML make sure to save your
file with DOT HTML extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an HTML file so in the last video we
installed an extension named live server
let me tell you how to use it and what
are the benefits of using live server so
let's write a basic HTML program or just
press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic HTML
program we have not done anything yet
just edit it a little bit we'll add a
heading tag and inside the heading tag
we will write a heading let's suppose we
are writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
but this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use Google Chrome
or whatever browser you are using and in
the vs code side by side we'll be using
it side by side now let's suppose we'll
change something here let's add a word
here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we'll be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with a
basic HTML code which has only tags in
it it will print that thing if I remove
this heading tag let me remove and
moment I save it it will print nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these HTML
tags are used to render HTML files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
HTML tags you can use as many tags
according to your requirements in our
first program we will write a single
line statement over the browser for that
we will need the script tag don't worry
if you don't know much about script Tech
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
JavaScript with HTML this is where HTML
and JavaScript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or Point towards the external script
through the SRC attribute we will see
the srci attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
a program so let's start with this
first
let's start the script tag
we are done with it now this cryptag we
have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write it is a
JavaScript method using which you can
print anything on the browser let's see
what document.write can do let's write
here something
document dot right
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
um
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to Simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press Ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to Simply code we can Define
JavaScript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will Point towards an
external Javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute SRC and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any Javascript file so
let's create a file bus name it as
crypt.js remember you have to save it
with DOT JS extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn we will save it the moment
we will save it here
there's something wrong I guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that JavaScript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.js
moment we will save it see the text is
changed here initially it was Hello
World welcome to Simply code but now it
is Hello World welcome to Simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external Javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed JavaScript with
HTML and now let's see some of the
features of document.right so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given you nine plus three let's see if
it works see it will give you the output
directly here document.write 9 plus 3 it
will give you at the output as 12.
similarly you will do any mathematical
task any calculation you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by
feet
see
you can see here 12 56 Square let's give
it another one 9 multiply 5 minus let's
suppose 3 and save it 3 9 into 5 is 45
and if you minus 3 from 45 you'll get 42
here is the answer for s42 56 is for 7
into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and 12 is for 9
plus 3. so with that we are done with
how to embed with a JavaScript with HTML
let's move on to another Concept in
JavaScript that is console.log console
log is a function in JavaScript that
works the same as document.write but it
will not print anything in the browser
let's give it a try let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write complete code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browser's console
go to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use Control
Plus shift plus I which I normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles courses Network and many more
but for now let's focus on Console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things we don't always
know what to expect as the output maybe
we expect a particular result but we
might get something else one way of
debugging our code is that we can pass a
value to this function here only and we
can check the result of that value out
of the code let's add two numbers here
so if you don't understand it basically
what we are doing for now we are writing
a small piece of code like the program
is not that big but later on when we are
good with JavaScript and we will use
JavaScript as a primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to check the output of your
code by doing that only so if you are
using any variables or you are using any
functions you can check the output here
only if you have to use that variable in
that way or you have to change something
so you will get it here only that's the
use of console.log let's add two numbers
remove it a is equal to 5 and let these
value is 8 suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we'll do we will write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is 13 you can do any
complex calculation here in the console
it will give you the correct answer you
can see here script.js column four the
number after the column is the line in
script dot JS here in our file we can
see that the console.log command is in
line number four so here it is written
that it is line number four here so if
you click on this
you can see the script.js opened in a
very small window and you can edit it
from here as well so this is not a
random line number to prove this let's
go on to our program and let's move this
to another line see now the console.log
is in line 11. save it and here you can
see this also changed to 11. so let's
make this more complex add another
variable C we'll add another variable
here let suppose we add C here we'll
give it a more complex equation let's
suppose let C equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer oh no we are done with the
equation let's change it here also the
value of
C is
let's see if it works or not press Ctrl
s it's saved and the value of C is seven
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27. 27 plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20 27 minus 20. the value of C is
7 say it's correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document dot right
so console log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program in the previous video we learned
about a first JavaScript program I
explained you some basic things like if
you want to perform addition if you want
to add two numbers or you want to
perform subtractions and multiplication
and division as well before moving
forward to statements and comments here
to take a note while you are performing
any calculation let me show you see if
you are performing any calculation let's
copy it from here and paste it here
so yeah if you want to perform and let's
add two numbers like we want to add 45
and
we'll add let's say 5. we will save it
and here you can see the answer is 50
here right so if you want to perform any
calculation you have to write as it is
you can't write any calculation within
inverted comma or double inverted comma
let's try this if you want to write any
calculation within a single inverted
comma the moment you save it it will
print it as 45 plus 5 what the browser
will do the browser will interpret it as
text and print it as it is so there will
be no change so keep that in mind take a
note of it and we are done with it right
now so let's move on to statements in
JavaScript so guys whenever you use any
programming language you give the
computer
some instruction to perform any task or
activity that's common in all
programming languages present out there
like you are giving computers a few
instructions to do a particular task
these instruction you are giving to the
computer are known as statements you see
the code written over here this
document.write function is an
instructional statement given to the
computer to write something on the
browser like if you are writing hello
world inside this function it will print
it in the browser as it is and same for
addition subtraction multiplication and
whatever you are writing inside it it
will basically print it on browser like
let's suppose if we write here something
else
let's suppose we write here inside
double
inverted comma
welcome to Simply code we save it we are
basically giving it the instruction to
write this on the browser so what it
will do it will write it as it is on the
browser these are the instructions we
are giving to a machine to perform a
basic task or to perform a certain task
so if you are writing a whole program
for designing a website or for anything
you must be using more than one
statement you will use a lot of
statements in a single program
so all these statements are separated by
semicolons like here you can see after
every statement I have written a
semicolon it's necessary let me show you
an example see we'll remove this
statement and we'll copy this line and
paste it in the next line and write
something else here but we can say this
is our first program we will write like
suppose I have written it I'll give it
the semicolon here the moment I'll save
it see you can see here it's written
that hello world the first statement
statement is interpreted and written
over here then second it come to welcome
to Simply code see here you can see that
I have not written any semicolon but
it's still showing the output
so let me tell you something interesting
so if you remove the semicolon from any
of these statement here it will work
fine which means JavaScript will forgive
you for these small errors you do but
it's always a good practice to put a
semicolon after every statement because
while writing a whole program in future
you will use n number of statements and
let's see what happen if you try to
write more than one statement in a
single line without any semicolon let's
do this thing here write more than one
statement in a single line and I'll save
it see it won't work the moment I put a
semicolon here and save it it will work
fine
so that's why I am saying that it is a
good practice to use semicolon after
each statement
hope you guys are getting this let's
move on to comments so a comment is also
common for almost all programming
languages it's a line in programming
language which do not have any effect on
the output of the program
it stays there in the code but it does
not affect the output by any means a
comment may be a multi-line comment or a
single line comment as well to write a
single line comment we just use double
slash in front of that statement like
here if we see the output is Hello World
welcome to Simply code this is our first
program
so to make this first statement a
comment what we'll do we'll use two
forward slashes in front of it and it
will become a comment so the moment we
will save it this hello world is
disappeared from the output
so this is how to use a single line
command a comment won't affect your
program by any means let's move on to
multi-line commands to write a
multi-line comment you have to use
forward slash along with the asterisk
sign see if you want to make these two
lines as comments to end a comment we
will use asterisk sign with a forward
slash these two statements are comments
now so the moment you will save it
welcome to Simply code is also
disappeared from the output that's how
comment work they won't affect your
programs output but comments are very
useful in programming it's just a note
for the programmers to remember what
they did at that particular part of the
program suppose you write a program see
here the programs are not that large and
the coding is not that much but in
future when you write a program maybe
the program will be of more than 500
lines or more so suppose you write a
program with more than 500 lines and
come back 20 days later so at that time
you can't go through the whole code this
is where comments will help you in
JavaScript it will help you to remember
what you did at that particular part of
the program so variables are named
storage that a program can manipulate as
the name suggests a variable is a value
that can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
JavaScript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to 15 we will
declare
where B and the value of B will be 6 we
will declare where
C and the value of C would be a plus b
so here we have defined three variables
a b and c a is a variable with value 15
stored inside it and so is B the value
of B is 6 but C is a variable that will
contain the value of a plus b let's try
to print this on browser
document dot right
and we will print the value of C
save it and here you can see the value
of C is 21.
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for a n
will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of C is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of B
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
2015 two more ways were introduced to
declare a variable these are let end
const we shall discuss these two terms
in the later part of this session let me
show you how to declare a variable there
are a few things you have to keep in
mind while declaring a variable name
here we have seen we use three variables
a b and c that was an easy task to do
but giving a variable any name like
something other than a single alphabet
so you have to keep a few things in mind
while naming them start them with the
letter underscore or a dollar sign you
can't use any sign except underscore or
dollar so if you are giving a variable
name you can't use any other sign except
the underscore or the dollar sign you
can use these two signs only you can't
use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in JavaScript JavaScript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
JavaScript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in JavaScript we'll
save it and see here throws an error
unexpected token Plus
but you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because JavaScript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
Let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and the another variable
will be where girl with capital G this
time JavaScript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for JavaScript as
JavaScript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variable let's comment this part as well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bikening where byte name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value cosine let's suppose we'll assign
it Yamaha
semicolon and press Ctrl s to save this
and here you can see the output as
Yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of Declaration only let's move
on to let and const so we will discuss
let and Cones but first we will compare
let with where let is also used to
declare a variable just like where is
used but there is a limitation to use
let
is not accessible outside the Block in
which it is declared
so we will use let here only let byte
name equals and we will change this
value as well we'll change it to Hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but if we try to put
this code inside a block let's suppose
we put this code inside this block a
pair of curly braces and we will again
try to access document dot right we'll
try to access bike name again from here
from outside the block we try to access
this save it and here you can see bike
name is not defined it is an error in
line 18. so what's happening here
basically you can't access a let
variable outside the scope you can't
access it from here but it will work
with where if we try to replace let with
where and save it here you can see it
says hero and hero because first it will
interpret this method and then it will
interpret this as well in case of where
due to its limited scope light variables
are used when there is limited use only
like in for Loop or in while loop we
will learn these Loop in future let will
not allow you to redeclare any variable
let's understand this with an example
here's the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we will try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to TVs Control Plus s it says
hero and TVs so the variable name the
bike name is same in both cases here and
here as well these are same but with
where keyword you can do that let will
not allow you to do this if we use let
here in place of where we'll write let
as here as well and we'll change the
value as well we will give it as
Kawasaki
and
let's suppose Suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same light variable
in different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change but
that will never change basically so the
keyword const is little misleading as it
defines a constant reference to a value
not the constant value we can't change
the Primitive value but we can change
the properties of constant objects let's
write another piece of code for const
keyword
so let's declare a variable const
X is equal to
5.
comma Y is equal to
7 let's say fonts
so here what we have done we declared a
variable X and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declare it this time with
const keyword and the variable Z which
is X Plus y we printed Z on the browser
and it shows the value as 12 which is X
Plus y 7 plus 5 is equal to 12. now what
we will do const will let you do this
but if you try to update the value of x
let's suppose we try to update the value
of x as x equals to X
Plus 10.
we'll print X this time
document.write
X let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const also const won't allow you to
redeclare any variable just like let so
if you try to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier X has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
lead it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential Concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable the type
of variable is holding basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way we discussed earlier that
JavaScript is a lightweight scripting
language because we don't need to
specify any data type in JavaScript
after all all the variables in
JavaScript are Loosely packed or we can
say JavaScript is a dynamically typed
scripting language we shall discuss
these properties later in this video for
now let me tell you about different data
types present in JavaScript
so JavaScript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-premitive data types they are stored
in Heap I don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings Boolean
undefined and null non-primitive data
types or complex data types we can say
on the other hand they are divided into
two parts arrays and objects will have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here let's
say we declare where X and give it the
value as 16th will declare where Y and
will give it value
hello world we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of JavaScript which I mentioned earlier
JavaScript variables are Loosely packed
and JavaScript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables X we
have defined variable X we have defined
variable Y and flag as well the values
for all three variables is different
from one another
see variable X is holding a value that
is 16 variable Y is holding a value
hello world which is a string so 16 is a
number hello world is a string and
variable flag is holding a value that
refers to a Boolean value in place of
true we can also write false here
so what's happening here here you can
see there is no data type if you are
coming from a C plus plus background or
a Java background this will be a little
bit weird for you guys because in C plus
plus and Java we used to do it like we
will define an integer let let me show
you
so how we will Define integer in C plus
plus or Java what we'll say we'll use
int x equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying C plus plus but here in
JavaScript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as Loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in JavaScript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
JavaScript which are number
Boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll Define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable P has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
I'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable P we'll check the type of P so
to use this operator you have to use it
with document dot right now
so we will do document.write and we'll
use two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like we want to
know the type of variable X let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here from X to Y in this line
and from X to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character for variable flag it says
Boolean so it's defined as true or false
and for variable P it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there's a difference between a
null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here's an example for
this C will declare one more variable
here we'll declare where num let's name
this variable num and we will give it
the value as null we will use
document.write type of and we will check
with the help of type of operator that
what type of value the variable num is
holding so let's give here num
we are good to go press Ctrl s and C
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object we'll talk about the complex
types or composite types in further
videos we'll have separate videos for
each of these types type conversion as
the name suggests conversion of value
from one to another in the previous
video we declared a few variables we
declared numbers strings and Boolean as
well in JavaScript you can change the
data type of any variable from one to
another you can change a number to a
string or a string to a number let's see
an example of type conversion let's
declare a variable here
let's suppose we are using a variable
let's say where num you can use
document.write as well there is no
problem with any method you are using
let's move ahead and we'll declare a few
more variables
we'll declare a string and a Boolean as
well
let's suppose where Str equals to
hello
and we'll print it as well let's copy it
from here and paste it here
and we'll declare one more variable
let's say where Bool equals to
true
let's print these three variables first
see the output is pretty simple we can
see the value and data types as well see
34 is a number hello is a string and
true is a Boolean value
so
let's convert this number to a string
first this number 34 this is a number
here right and we'll convert this number
to a string so how to do it that's
pretty simple all you have to do is
write a word here let's write here write
string with a capital s
and put 34 inside a bracket so here we
are done with it save it and see here
you can see 34 which was a number first
and now it's changed to a string
that's how you can change the data type
of any variable let's try to change a
Boolean value to a string now many of
you guys gets confused with Boolean so
Boolean is nothing
if something is true then set it to true
and if something is not true like if
it's false then set it to false see if
we talk about a real life example say if
you know how to drive create a variable
drive and set it to true and if you
don't know how to write set the variable
to false that's pretty simple that's
what Boolean is let's change a Boolean
variable to a string we have to follow
the same steps as we did for numbers
what we did we'll write here string and
put true inside brackets
we are done with it save it and check
the output here you can see the type
change from Boolean to string like
string function we can also change a
string value to a number
so how to do it let's take a variable
let's say where str1 will take let's say
we are giving it a numeric value let's
say eight nine six eight
and what we'll do we'll write here
console log and will print it basically
str1 and we'll write here as well
save it and here you can see 8968 is a
string so how to change this string to a
number that's also a simple task all you
have to do is write here number with
capital n and put this value inside
brackets
save it and see here you can see 8968
changed to a number it was a string
earlier and now it's a number so if it's
a number now let's update this number
and we will see if we are adding
something to 8968 the value will change
or not let's update str1 what we'll do
we'll write str1 equals to str1
plus let's add a number say
so the output should be eight nine seven
zero and the type of operator will give
the value as number let's see what's the
output now save it and see here you can
see the output changed to 8970 but if
you add an alphabet or a character in
the value then the output will be
different here we will copy this whole
code
and we'll paste it here
we'll change the value of str1 equals to
str2 and we'll use an alphabet along
with this number let's suppose it's 8968
a so a is in alphabet and what we'll do
we'll comment this line and we'll go
here and change the value str1
here we are done with it save it here
you can see it says n a n it means that
it's not a number it won't treat this
string as a number because it consists
of both numeric value as well as
character
now let's try to convert a Boolean value
to a number in the case of a Boolean
variable the scenario is a bit different
let's try this
let's declare a variable let's say we
are using where Bool 2
and the value will be true
what we'll do we'll print the value here
you can see true and the data type of
true is Boolean so let's try to change
this Boolean value to a number that's
pretty simple task write a number and
put true inside brackets
save it and here you can see it says one
in case of Boolean variable the value of
true is 1 and the value of false is 0.
remember this guys keep this thing in
mind if you are changing a Boolean
variable to a number then the value of
true will be changed to 1 and the value
of false will be changed to 0.
now let's have a look at percent and
parse float as well after which I'll
tell you one more interesting function
let's move on to percent first here I'll
declare a variable let's suppose I am
declaring a variable let's say where and
we'll name this variable as number
the value will be a string let's suppose
it's 56
we print it console.log
here you can see that the output is
showing 56 is a string so the data type
here is string because I have used here
single inverted comma so it will take 56
as a string
now
let's suppose I want to parse this as an
integer or say I want to change it to a
number I can use percent as well apart
from number if you want to use number
that's fine but apart from number if you
want to use percent you can use it
let's see what happens if you use
parsint use percent and put 56 inside a
bracket
save it and see here it changed the
string to a number 56 was a string
earlier right and now it's a number just
like percent we have parse float as well
parse float will do the same thing but
what if you are using a decimal number
here let's see if you are using 56.343
save it
but percent will do it will give you
let's change 56 first let's suppose we
are using 65 now save it and see percent
will give you the value as 65 only it
won't show you the value the decimal
value
but if you are using here number or pass
float it will give you the whole numeric
value let's see what happens if you use
number here
number and save it here you can see the
value is
65.343 like number if you are using here
pass float
let's use parse float here
and we'll change the value here as well
let's suppose it's 72 point
543 save it and see here it will give
you the whole numeric value of the
variable I hope this is clear for you
guys
now there is one more function you can
use in numbers which is dot 2 fixed so
this function has by default zero value
let's suppose I am using here we have to
use it here only let's see what happens
if I'm using number Dot
to fixed
so inside bracket we are giving it a
value by default the value is 0 Let's
suppose we are giving it the value as 2.
now save it and what will happen it will
give you the value as 72.54 similarly if
you are using here some other number
let's suppose seven you can see we have
only three digits here after the decimal
we have three digits only that is five
four and three what happens if we run
this program now let's save it and see
it says five four three zero zero zero
zero so it will show you the value up to
seven decimal points it doesn't matter
if there are available numbers after
decimal point but it will show you the
value instead of 7 you can also give
here 30 let's save it and see it says
6366 and so on hope this is clear for
you guys in any programming language an
operator is a symbol that makes the
computer understand that it needs to do
some specific tasks like if we want to
perform an addition between two numbers
let's say we want to perform addition
between four and five so guys if you see
the plus sign here this is known as the
operator and the two terms which are
four and five these two numbers these
are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have Plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well so there are many more
operators present in almost every
programming language which is present
out there like it operators are present
in Java they are present in C plus plus
in C almost every programming language
out there has the concept of operators
it's essential for you to know how and
where to use any operator despite of the
language you are working on one needs to
understand which operators are available
right so in this particular video I'll
take you through the basic types of
operator present in JavaScript I'll let
you know the types and we'll learn about
how to use them and of course I'll take
you through the different categories of
operators present in JavaScript so in
JavaScript there are basically eight
categories into which operators are
divided which are we have arithmetic
operators we have assignment we have
string we have conditional we have
logical bitwise comparison and type of
operator we'll discuss the first three
types in this video that is we'll
discuss the arithmetic operators we'll
discuss the assignment and the string
operators rest we'll talk about in the
following video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic right
so arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well so
here are the few operators you can see
on your screen the plus operator minus
asterisk division we have modulus we
have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys I want to
mention one more thing here I want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators you will create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics
we'll cover in future from today so I
want you to create a separate file
because you know in future if you want
to access these topics it will be easy
for you to access those files instead if
you are using a single file for all the
topics it will be quite confusing so
let's start with the arithmetic
operators first let's take two variables
we are in the Javascript file let's take
two variables let's say where x equal
equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication I have
commented the division because I have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's six plus four
similarly for subtraction and
multiplication it is 6 minus 4 and it's
6 multiplied by 4.
for division I have left division
because I hope you guys know the
difference between Division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll comment these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll paste this here and
we'll use the modulus here so now let's
check the output what it says for
division and modulus
see we have divided 6 by 4 division it
says it's 1.5 6 divided by 4 that is 1.5
it will show the quotient here for
modulus it's saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in division it gives you the
quotient as the answer so keep this
thing in mind guys keep this in mind
always take a note of it so we are done
with division and modulus next up we
have the increment and The decrement
Operators let me show them to you real
quick so what we'll do we'll declare
another variable let's say where Z
equals to 5.
and we'll use the increment operator
here we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus plus whatever variable you have
used so we'll use plus plus Z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens let me give
some space in between them so that you
won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
says 5. so you can see here the
functioning of decrement and increment
operator the increment operator will
increase the value of Z by 1 and the
decrement operator will do the opposite
of this L decrease the value by 1. so we
are done with the arithmetic operators
next up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different JavaScript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals to
and we have multiplied equals to we have
divide equals to modulus equals to and a
few more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every single operator out
there which is present in your screen so
let's move on and see let's move on to
the programming part so here we are guys
let's declare a few variables let's say
we are declaring a variable a and we are
giving it the value as 10 suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where B and give it the value
5. so for assignment operators what
assignment operator mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10. this
means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
I hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind so we have the value 10 and
we are assigning this value to the
variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10. and similarly the value of B
is 5. so let's do one more thing we'll
assign the value of a to B how to do
this let's change the value here only
let's suppose we are using the value of
where a is 13 okay and the value of
where we will be providing as let's say
a
so now let's try to print the value of B
here we'll change
will print the value of B only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of B is 13. because we
have assigned B the value present at
variable a which is 13. that's why it is
showing the value of b as 13. this is
what assignment operator is let's try
other assignment operators as well
let's take another variable
so let's say where even
equals to let's say 51. so the next
operator we will be using is let's
update the value of A1 first so how to
do this let's say A1 equals to no it's a
1 plus equals to 9.
and we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of A1 is 60 here
we have given that A1 plus equals to 9
see even plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here A1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to A1
Plus 9. both of these lines are same
both these statements means the same
they are performing the same task so A1
equals to A1 Plus 9 is same as a 1 plus
equals to 9. that's what I want you to
understand with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals to you can do it as well so
let's say A1 minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of A1 so in the
first statement when we try to print A1
here the initial value was 51 then this
statement was performed and the value
was updated to 60. then after that one
more statement this statement is also
performed and the value updated to 69
it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value we
have here is 69. now what happens if we
are using the minus equals to operator
what it will do it will decrease the
value of A1 by 5. it means that A1
equals to A1 minus 5 the value of A1 is
69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of A1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this so we
have so many operators we have so many
of them like let's try a few more so we
have multiply equals to we have division
equals to we have modulus equals to so
I'll write these and then we'll see the
output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for A3 A4 and A5 you can see
for A3 we have used multiply equals to
for A4 we have used divide equals to and
for A5 we have used modulus equals to
let's check the output here
save it and see it says the value of
a350
it here we have taken a3s5 it's 10 into
5 because A3 equals to A3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of A4 is 3.75
because we have used your food so
instead of 4 let's try to use 3 and save
it see here you can see it divides it
and gives you the quotient and the value
of A4 divided by 3 is 5.
so similarly for A5 it shows the value
of A5 is 6.
because we have used the modulus
operator here N20 divided by 7 we have
6s remainder
so I hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in JavaScript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for Strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is full so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world but there is no space
between hello end World keep this point
in mind guys so if you are adding two
strings just like this there will be no
space between the two strings so if you
want to add any space between these two
what you have to do you have to mention
it here separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings so now
let's save it now and see here you can
see there is a space between hello and
world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do we'll use the plus
equal to operator here str3 plus equals
to
let's say
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now see here you can see it says
hello world for the first str1 plus str2
it says hello world for str3 it says
welcome to Simply code see here the
space is already given so it will show
this in the output but between welcome
and 2 if you want to add space you have
to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here as well
plus sign yes save it now and see here
you can see it says welcome to Simply
code with proper space now we will cover
the rest of the operators now we are
left with five more these are the first
three operators now we are left with
conditional operators logical operators
we have bitwise operator and we have
comparison and finally we have the type
of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today before we start
with the operators let us first discuss
associativity talking about
associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b so the direction
in which this expression will be
evaluated either it will be from left to
right or from right to left so this is
known as associativity let's understand
it with the help of an example
so here you can see I have taken three
variables I have taken variable a and I
have assigned it value as 12. I have
taken variable B and the value assigned
to B is 8 and finally I have a variable
result which stores the value of a plus
b
lastly what I am doing is I'm printing
out the result variable inside the H1
tag here you can see I have used the H1
tags and I have used the plus operator
to concatenate the strings right I have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result so the plus operator here is
doing two different tasks right here you
can see it is performing the addition of
two numbers right and here you can see
it is used to concatenate two strings so
now let's talk about associativity
because I guess you guys are cleared
with string operator till now we have
discussed them in the previous video
right so let's talk about associativity
now so certain operators have right to
left associativity and certain operators
have left to right associativity
so when I say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable C
and we are giving it the value as
5 and what we'll do we'll update result
as well let me first show you the output
of this particular program see the
output will be value of result is 20 and
high there high there is concatenated
with the string value of result is N20
is the actual answer the 20 is the value
of result so let's add one more variable
here let's say we are adding a variable
C and the value of C will be 5. what
we'll do now we will update result as
well here you can see I have done a plus
b plus c
save it and here you can see the value
updated to 25 the value of result is
updated right so the plus operator has
associativity from left to right till
now we have talked about right to left
as for assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of C will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25 we
know that JavaScript is a Loosely typed
programming language right which means
that we don't have to specify data types
every time like we are using if we are
using any data type we don't need to
specify it every time like let's do one
thing let's add a string here so what
we'll do we'll add a string let's
suppose I'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
Plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the sensitivity of the plus operator is
from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello 12 8 and
5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting as string
here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do we'll remove this string from
here and we'll add it somewhere else
let's say we are adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable D and the value will be 10.
and what we'll do we'll perform a plus b
before the string and then we'll perform
C plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it it says 20 hello 510 so when it
reached out the first variable it finds
out that the first variable is a number
so it added the first two numbers right
it added 12 and 8 the answer is 20 then
it came across this string hello and
then finally it assumed that everything
ahead of this will be a string so that's
the output 20 is the addition of a plus
b and then the string hello and finally
we have the value of c and d as string
so we have the value 5 and 10 not 15
right I hope you guys get this
so let's move on to conditional
operators the conditional operators
assign a value to a variable based on a
certain condition like it contains a
condition and you know for every
condition like there exists only two
possibilities either it can be true or
it can be false there is nothing else
you can do with a conditional operator
so it works the same as if else
statements which we'll cover in further
videos the only difference between if
else and conditional operators that it
takes less time or we can say its usage
is pretty easy
so here is the Syntax for conditional
operators so it seems pretty
straightforward right so here you can
see we have a variable name we have a
condition depending upon the condition
we have two values here's the example as
well C you can see we have a variable
voter next up we have a condition if age
is less than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15. so it will check if
15 is less than 18 it's true then it
will print 2m or if the value of H is
greater than 80 then it will print false
or you can say it will print old in a
few
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 30. what we'll do in variable y I
have given it a condition so it will
check for X which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equals to 50.
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if you update the value of XL let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right also if you want to write
a message here only you can do it write
it here as so we'll copy it from here
we'll copy document.write
and we'll paste it here
let's remove this document dot right and
we what we'll do we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write value of
so
and now what we'll do will save it
see it says value of true so or you can
write any other message here as well you
can write value of x is greater than or
you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now see here it says value is
greater value of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a condition like here it is
it's a it has a condition and it has two
values right it has true or false so
that's why it is also known as ternary
operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables or values we can say we use
logical operators to check whether
multiple conditions are true or false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in JavaScript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or note are the three
operators present in JavaScript
the end operator here you can see it it
is holding two values right it it has X
less than 10 and y greater than one so
the end operator will return true only
if both the conditions are true like X
has to be less than 10 and Y has to be
greater than 1. so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and Y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why the output of the and
operator will be true for our operator
the case is a bit different so if any
one of these two conditions like we have
two conditions if any one of these two
is true then the output will be true and
if both are false then only the output
will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to Y if the
value X is holding is equals to that of
Y if the value is not equal then it will
return true
I hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value X and Y
holding if they are not equal then it
will return true if they are equal then
it will return false right
we'll understand the programming concept
of logical operators in further videos
when we learn about control statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen these
are the different types of comparison
operators present in JavaScript we have
equals to we have not equals to we have
equal value and data type we have
greater than less than and we have a few
more so I hope you guys must remember
from the previous video that a single
equals to operator is an assignment
operator so if we are using a single
equals to then it will be considered as
an assignment operator for comparison we
have to use double equal to keep this
thing in mind whenever you are using any
operator in JavaScript or especially the
equals to operator so if you want to
compare two values you have to use
double equals to because single equals 2
is used to assign values this is an
assignment operator so let's move on to
the programming part now
so guys here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 10. this code seems a little bit
longer to you but that's a simple piece
of code like I have used almost every
comparison operator we came across in
the previous slide I have used each one
of them and I've used the document dot
right after every comparison operator to
put some spaces in between so that you
guys don't confuse between them so let's
check the output now see you as you can
see I have used the double equals to the
triple equals to I have used X not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with 8. and 10 and 8 are not
equals to so the output will be false as
similar for 10 and we have used the
triple equals to operator which means
equal value and data type so both 10 and
8 have equal data type they both have
the same data type that is number but
the values are different so it will
print false
for X not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for X not equals to equals to it it will
check that both the values are not equal
but the data types are equal right so it
will print true for this as well for X
greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater than 8
so it will print true
similarly for it will check for X
smaller than 8 and it will check for X
greater than equals to it and also for X
less than equals to it
so by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you put to the right of it like if
you are using any data type and you want
to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say so you can
use the type of operator it will tell
you the actual data type of any variable
so in JavaScript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
Boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see I have used four
different variables which are I've used
variable X variable Y and variable flag
and variable P so the values are
different the x is holding 17 why is
holding header and flag has the value as
false and I have defined P but I have
not assigned it any value till now so
what I'll do I have used the type of
operator to find out the type of every
variable like here I have used it for X
for y for flag and for p
let's check the output now
save it and see it says number string
Boolean and undefined see here we have
given X the value as 17. so 17 is a
number then it says it is a number for
here it says it is a string for false it
says it is a Boolean value like in
Boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable P it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to any variable like you are using
the variable as it is like here we have
not given it any value so if you are
doing this the type of operator will
return undefined so let's take an
example of null as well let's declare
another variable let's say where ABC
and will give it the value as null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable ABC is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost 7
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers if you
know the numbers are stored in binary
format bitwise operators work on 32-bit
numbers and we have decimal numbers like
we understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then convert it back to a JavaScript
number
so
here you can see on your screen we have
four different bitwise operators we have
the and operator we have or we have node
and we have zor or we can say exclusive
or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see we have used the
and operator before as well while we
were in logical operators but the syntax
was different and
here you can see we have a single
Ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have X as 5
here you can see X is first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work let's take an example of
bitwise operators
so here you can see I have taken two
variables I have taken variable X and
the value of variable X is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then I have used all the four
bitwise operators like I have used X and
Y I have used X or Y I have used not X
and I have used the xor operator between
X and Y so let's check the output now
here you can see if we talk about the
output see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and
4. so for X and Y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for end
operators it will return 1 if both the
values are 1. if any one of the two
values are 0 then it will return 0. so
what it will return here it will return
0 for 0 0 for 1 0 it will also return 0.
similarly for 0 0 it will also return 0
and for 1 1 it will return 1 which is
the binary equivalent of 1. so the
answer here is 1.
for x or y it will return 1 if any one
of the two values are 1. see if both are
0 it will return 0. if any one of the
two values is 1 it will return 1.
it will return 0 again and finally it
has two ones so it will return 1. and 0
1 0 1 is the binary equivalent of five
that's why the output here is 5.
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
C minus x minus 1 will be minus 5 minus
1 which is minus 6 so this is a bit
different here the not operator here is
a bit different for xor operator or we
can say exclusive or it will return four
why it will return 4 it will return 1
when any one of the two values is one if
both are 1 then also it will return
false it will return 1 only in one
condition if any one of the two values
is 1 then only it will return one that's
why the output here
the output here will be 0 1 0 0 that's
why it's written as 4 which is the
binary equivalent of 0 1 0 0. so let's
take a look at control statements with
the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that is n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement 1 till statement n and it will
execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu every time
for example let's suppose you are in
line 5 and you want to print this line
10 times so what should you do you can
write this line 10 times or you can copy
paste it right okay let's forget about
10 times let's suppose you have to use
this code or we can say let's suppose we
have to print this statement 100 times
doing this like copy pasting it for 100
times or writing this statement for 100
times that's useless and unnecessary
right so that's where control statements
comes into picture we'll discuss them in
a while let's assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in JavaScript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity like if we
want to perform a certain activity n
number of times or if you want to make a
certain decision making kind of
scenarios in your program that's where
we need control statements in JavaScript
in JavaScript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's where we use conditional
statements we have two different types
of conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch keys
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times instead of
writing them again and again
we use Loops so Loops are basically
statements we use Loops to perform any
activity n number of times with specific
conditions
so in JavaScript we have four different
type of Loops we have for Loop while
loop do while loop and foreign Loop
so the for Loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages but this
foreign Loop this is a new type of loop
present in JavaScript we use foreign
loop with objects we'll go through
objects in upcoming videos and of course
we will be looking at each of these
control statements in detail
will have a particular video for each of
these topics
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements the break is used to
exit a switch statement or Loop like
when used in a loop it breaks the loop
and continues executing the code after
it
and on the other hand the continue
statement breaks a single iteration when
used in a loop when we use continuous
statement in a loop it breaks a single
iteration and it breaks the iteration
only if the specified condition occurs
and then it will continue with the next
titration in the loop so the if else
conditional statement is used whenever
we work with condition it can be either
a single condition or maybe more than
one condition or multiple conditions we
can work with
so let's try to write a basic program
with a single condition so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
elsif statement so we'll create a new
file today so I hope you guys know the
importance of creating a separate file
for every topic you know it will be easy
for you to work to find out that
separate file later if you want to
revise that topic so here is the program
where we have taken a variable X and the
value of x is 10. so what we are doing
in this program is we are checking if
the value the variable X is holding that
is value 10. and if the value is less
than
10 or if the value is greater than 10.
so we have only two conditions either
the value can be less than 10 or the
value can be greater than 10 or equals
to 10 is
so here in this program what we'll do
we'll first we'll update this value as 8
so the variable X is holding the value
8. so to check the output let's save it
and here you can see it says the value
of x is less than 10. of course the
value 8 is always less than 10 right so
for 8 that's fine it will say the value
is less than 10 and similarly if we do
the same for let's say 11 save it now
and see it says the value of x is
greater than 10. so that's quite simple
right but what if we are giving the
value as 10. we know 10 is equals to 10
so save it now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
10.
this is happening because what we did we
as we told The Interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only X is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10 so here
what it is doing it is checking if the
value is less than 10 so that it says
okay let's print this statement if the
value is less than 10 or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals 2 or greater than 10
it will print the value of x is greater
than 10. to write this type of
misunderstanding we use an elsif
statement so the concept of else if
statement is the same as if statement
but we are doing we are using multiple
conditions right we are giving it more
than one condition so how to use L6 it's
quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an else if so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value X is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10.
and what we will do will update it as
so let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to time right so I hope you
guys are getting this the execution flow
for this program will be like it will
check for the first condition if x is
less than 10 if yes it will print the
value of x is less than 10. if no it
will move on the to the following
condition like under the else if
statement it finds a condition that if x
is equals to 10 it will check for it if
yes if x is equals to 10 then it will
print the value of x is equals to 10.
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that if x
is less than 10 or if x is equals to 10.
now we'll take a look at some basic
programs other than this one we'll take
a look at a few more basic programs
so here's the another program what we
are doing here is we are taking a
variable X and the value of x is 5. so
what we are doing is we are checking if
the number is an even number or an odd
number the thing you have to keep in
mind is the logic to find whether a
number is even or an odd number so to
check uh whether a number is even you
what we do we'll divide that number with
two right but basically we want is we
want the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written X mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the reminder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even and odd number
so here we are with another program here
it says we have a variable Y and the
value of y is
let's say
eight and what we are doing here is we
are checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero so we have three
different conditions either number can
be positive or it can be a negative
number Any number greater than 0 is a
positive number right and any number
less than zero is a negative number and
the third one is a number zero it's
neither positive non-negative so let's
check for the number eight save it and
see here you can see it is a positive
number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0. so these two
programs are quite simple guys right the
conditions are pretty simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative and at the same time we'll
check for even an odd also if you are
giving any number as input like let's
suppose we are using 5 we'll check if
the number is positive or negative and
odd or even so we'll do this
simultaneously let's move on to this
program so there are two ways to check
whether the number is positive or
negative and odd or even
so the two methods we'll discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement so this one here
you can see right in front of your
screen is
the nested if method so here you can see
we have used the if statement we have
given one more condition inside another
if statement so first it will check
whether a number is positive or not for
X greater than 0 it will check if the
number X is greater than 0 then if yes
if it will find it that yes this number
is greater than 0 then it will move on
to the nested if and it will check for
odd or even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number is
positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so here
you can see the difference but The
Interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nestative and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd so if it finds that the
number is even it will print negative
and even otherwise it will print
negative and odd and the last condition
is for the number 0. let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as 8. so save it now here it says the
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well let's update the
value of x as minus 5. save it now it
says negative and odd number minus 5 is
a negative odd number right so that's
how it will check for positive
or negative end odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program we have an alternate method as
well here you can see on your screen we
have written a program and here we have
taken a variable X the functioning of
both the programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and odd or even
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X let's say the value of x is
7. it will check for X greater than 0
and x mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so
we have four different conditions right
a number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
and odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is 0. okay we have five
conditions and we have to specify these
four conditions here so here we you can
see we are using the logical and
operator this means it will print this
statement let's suppose for this
statement it will print this only if
both the conditions are true right if
the number if the value X is holding is
both greater than 0 and an even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and out
so the number seven is greater than zero
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is positive and odd the
switch case is another conditional
control statement and just like the if
else control statement there is a
difference between the usage of if else
and switch case statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use which case over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user for an input
between 50 and 100 a numeric input
basically and in the output we have to
print the textual form of that number
suppose if the user enters 75 right the
output will be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else or we can say
else if control statement but the
program will be so lengthy and not so
clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option we'll get to know why in a
bit so let's move on to the programming
part and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number so we have 12 months in a
year for example if we enter 4 then the
output will be April and if we enter 8
then the output will be August because
August is the eighth month of the year
right so I hope you guys are clear with
the question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using IF else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario so let's create a
variable first let's say we are creating
a variable where month and
you can give any value to this variable
from 1 to 12. you can provide it with
any initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and the value we are providing it
one as the hardcore initial value for
Simplicity again we are not taking the
input from the user or from the browser
to do so we have to first go through the
Dom manipulations and we'll go through
it in later videos so let's start with
the switch case now
the Syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as one for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so next up we have an open and curly
braces for the body of the switch case
we have to test for 12 different
conditions inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value month variable might
hold like 1 2 3 and so on followed by a
colon right so we have to write the
value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a column
keep this thing in mind guys and below
that we are going to write what we want
when the value is 1 like what the output
we want when the value is 1 so we have
to write document
dot right
and
whatever you want as the output like for
when the first month is January so we
are writing here
January
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is 1 you
will get the output as January save it
and here you can see the output is
January
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
January right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is once
we are done with the output we get our
output right once we are done with case
1 we get our output as January this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch keys so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case so let's say we are writing a one
more case as
case two
and the output will be
document dot right
the second month is February right
and February we can write so
we'll include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says January
so if we don't include this break
statement here when The Interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is 1 right
so it will print January
but it will print other statements as
well so for example if we remove this
break statement and save it now see you
can see here the output as January and
February January and February both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here see
the value is 1 and if we include break
statement here
the moment The Interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as January it
will come out of the switch keys
so I hope you guys are getting this
similarly we'll write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be June if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
October and so on and so forth
now the question here is what if we try
to write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that if we try
to write any value other than these 12
values from 1 to 12 if if you leave
these values then if we try to write
another value like if we write here 13.
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see there is no output and
there might be no error for this as well
so if you try to check for an error go
to inspect and check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here default
with a colon and right
document
dot right and let's suppose we are
writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program First Press Ctrl s and now
you can see it says raw input for value
13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right analysis
statement we don't need to specify any
particular condition any condition other
than the if condition or else if
condition will fall inside the else
statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so you must include this default case in
your program every time by using switch
case because it's quite useful you know
okay so this is the complete program to
find out the month by accepting its
number
so if you try
six
and save it now it will say Zoom if you
try 10 save it it will say October if
we'll try 12 save it it will say
December so I hope this is clear to you
guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because the switch case in
JavaScript Works differently from other
languages like switch cases also present
in C plus plus and Java but in
JavaScript it is a bit different so in
JavaScript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and Boolean values as
well now let's have a look at how the
switch case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is June right and you can see
use this string in case as well so here
you have to give the case as a string
value right because we are using switch
case statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be June the output should
be sixth month and when the value is
July the output will be seventh month so
let's check it out if this is working or
not let's save this program and see for
June it says sixth month and similarly
we can check it for July as well let's
check for July
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to it will be similar like
there's no difference for default case
let me show you how
will write here wrong input
save it and now let's try to change the
value here let's say we are using May
save it and see it says wrong input what
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use 2 save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well it will give you the
output when the value is either June or
July
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for Boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for Boolean values so what you
have to do instead of 2 you have to give
here a Boolean value let's suppose you
are writing here true and for true you
have to change the case as well for true
you have to change the output as let's
say for true it the output will be 1.
okay and similarly for false
the output should be 0.
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now and
see here for true it says one the output
you can see here is one and if you try
to do the same for false like let's
write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says 0.
you can see the output is correct right
so we will discuss uh our first
iterative control statement that is the
for Loop in JavaScript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements we'll make a
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for Loop which is the first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that we use for Loop when
we are clear with the number of
iterations in advance so let's start
with our first program in this program
we will print the multiplication table
of 10 from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10.
let's start with coding
first we write the four keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally we have the increment or
decrement
so this is the Syntax for for Loop next
up we have the open and the closed curly
braces for the body of for Loop we'll
change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one so we'll what
we'll do we'll leave it here only we'll
change it from here so in the
initialization part what we are going to
do is we'll create a variable let's say
we are creating a variable where a and
the value of and the initial value of a
will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for Loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use because sometimes what
happens is the loop runs forever because
of a wrong condition which will
ultimately crash our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for Loop should execute here in
this case we want to print the table of
10 right we want to have 10 iteration
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to n and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10.
it will start from a equals to 1 and it
will go till a less than or equals to 10
and next up we'll use the increment
operator we want to increment the value
of a by 1 every time right so we'll use
increment operator a plus plus or we can
say a equals to A plus 1 both are the
same things right so here the condition
will be like this for variable a equals
to 1 a less than equals to 10 and a plus
plus
so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will will be
increased by 1 every time because we
have used the increment operator right
next up the body of for Loop will go
like so what we want to print if we want
to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot right and inside document.right
we'll use the H1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so we'll
multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser so we'll close
the H1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100. so
what is happening is firstly the for
Loop is also known as the entry control
Loop it means that the condition is
checked initially the first time the for
Loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value is stored at variable a
is 1. initially the value is 1 next up
it will check for a less than equals to
10 is a which is 1 is 1 less than equals
to 10 then true the control will be
shifted to document.write and it will
print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2. now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10. now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11.
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10. no we
know that 11 is not less than equal to
10 right then it comes out of the loop
and it will print nothing after that so
this is the basic working of the for
Loop we'll go through one more program
wherein we'll print the odd numbers
between 1 and 10. so what are odd
numbers odd numbers are those numbers
which are not divisible by 2 right so we
have the odd number says 1 3 5 7 9 and
we want to print them so the difference
between each number is of 2 the 1 plus 2
plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right so what we
have to do is we have to write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2. and instead of writing
here 10 into a because this time we
don't want to print any multiplication
table we want to print a number only
right so we'll use a only save it and
check the output it says
13579 so these are the odd numbers
present between 1 and 10.
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for Loop while loop is also an entry
control Loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for Loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for Loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times we'll start with the
programming part now and then we will
discuss more about when to use while
loop over for Loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number let's
say we want to print all the odd numbers
up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right
we came across the same program in the
previous video as well but this time we
will use the while loop instead of for
Loop so the Syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use the code goes
like we start with the while keyword
then opening and closing round round
brackets and finally the body of while
loop in curly braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we use the for Loop we had
three different parts right we had the
initialization we had conditions and the
increment decrement part here we have
only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable X and the value
of x will be 1.
we used a 1 because 1 is the very first
odd number right after that inside the
condition what we want to do is we want
to print the odd numbers up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
X less than equals to 50. so the loop
will go till X is less than or equals to
50. or we can say x less than 15 that
depends on us if we want to check for 50
or not so the odd numbers will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to 50. so the last odd
number will be 49 so inside the while
loop we will print the value of x so
here we will print the value of x let's
print it
document dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the H1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite Loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for Loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well then we had
the condition we have a condition here
as well and then finally it has an
increment or decrement part right so
here we don't have that same increment
or decrement part we have to do it
separately so we'll increment the value
of x here only so here we will write X
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as x equals to X plus 2. you guys
are aware of it right so the reason is
simple because we want to go from 1 to 3
to 5 and so on that's why we use X plus
equals to 2. we incremented the value of
x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says one three
five seven nine and so on and so forth
till 49 so 49 is the last odd number
before 50 because we are checking
between 1 and 50 right so 49 is the last
odd number let me show you how the
program goes into an infinite Loop so
for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
Loop looks like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to open a new tab and
then again we have to run the program
with correct increment part so here you
can see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
1 up to 50 and the last one is 49.
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for Loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for Loop so where to use while loop
over for Loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is y we want
to do something let's say we want to
print something on the screen or if the
input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the Dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do while loop in
JavaScript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for Loop and the
while loop are entry control Loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control Loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the loops
body thus an exit control loop executes
at least once even if the test condition
fails or we can say the condition is
wrong the loop will execute once using
the do while loop is relatively easy it
seems like we are giving the system a
command to do something while the
condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we'll write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the Dual Loop
the do part and the while part or we can
say the condition part while part is the
part where we write the condition
so let's Define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable X and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while X
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5. or if the value of x is
smaller than or equal to 5 it will come
out of the loop in the do part we will
write what we want to do let's say we
want to print a single sentence here we
write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always so if
we try to save this program and let's
try to run this here you can see the
output is welcome to Simply code a
single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the Dual Loop will
perform this particular statement when
the document.write will be performed
after that it will check for the
condition if x is greater than 5 or not
if we use a 6 instead of 5. let's try to
write here 6 instead of 5 and if we run
this program now it will go into an
infinite Loop because we are not
performing the increment decrement
operator here right as we have discussed
in the previous videos the importance of
increment decrement part so we need to
do it here after the document.write part
so what we'll do here we'll write x
minus minus today we are using x minus
minus and for the other two Loops we use
the plus increment operator right so the
x minus minus is the same as x equals to
x minus 1. let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to Simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition and it
will print here welcome to Simply code
for the first time when the loop will
start executing it will first perform
this statement and it will write here
welcome to Simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1. so when
the value of x is 5 then it will check
for the condition if x is greater than 5
or not so here we can see clearly X is
not greater than 5 because x equals to 5
n it is equals to 5 right so it will
come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x and we'll use a
space so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the BR tag and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simplicode every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do I Loop when we
want the code to Output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
Dual Loop this video is just a syntax
demonstration we'll go through the
examples of all the three Loops present
in JavaScript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate Loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each Loop
we'll go through so let's start this
session with the first problem statement
so the first problem statement goes like
this so here we have to write a program
to check whether a number is prime or
not I hope you guys are aware of what
prime numbers are right so a prime
number is a positive number that is only
divisible by 1 and itself for example 2
3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right if we take
an example let's say we are taking an
example of 7 so 7 is a number which is
divisible by 1 and 7 only no other
number can divide 7 right so here in
this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first so we have a
variable number and the value of
variable number can be any random value
like any number you want to check if the
number is prime number or not you can
give that value to the variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime
whose value is a Boolean value right it
can be true for a prime number or it can
be false for a non-prime number so we
have used comments in this program to
make it easier for you guys to
understand so here we have used the if
statement to check if the number is 1
because we know that 1 is neither a
prime number nor a composite number
right so we have to check if the user
enters the value one or if we are giving
the value 1 we have to check for it so
if user enters the value 1 it will print
this statement that 1 is neither prime
nor composite
here in elseif we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for Loop present inside the else if
statement right here you can see we have
the for Loop here the control will be
shifted to this for Loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable I
and the initial value is set to 2 that's
because any prime number is divisible by
1 as well right so it won't make any
sense to include one here will start
from 2 and we'll check until the value
of I becomes half of the value of number
so if we take an example of 10 we'll
check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now I hope you guys are aware of
how to use for Loop and why we are using
for Loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for Loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
Loop so then we have the I plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of I by 1 after every iteration until
the value of I becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent I equals
to equals to zero so here is the main
condition to check if the number is
divisible by I or not so the execution
will be like if we are taking here a
number 10 it will start from 2 and it
will check if the remainder is 0 or not
so if the remainder is 0 then the value
of is prime will be changed to false and
it will come out of the loop
next it will check for the value of is
prime if the value of S Prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print n or we
can say then it will print that the
number is a prime number else it will
print that the number is not a prime
number if the value of is prime is false
for example when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of S Prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0 or
we can say the remainder will be 0 so
the value of S Prime will be changed to
false and for false it will print number
is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than one if the number entered
by the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take here minus 5. so
it will print the number is not a prime
number
Because by the usual definition of prime
numbers any negative number cannot be a
prime number that's a usual definition
right so we have to keep this thing in
mind and here in this else Loop we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and the output says 83 is a prime number
as 83 is not divisible by any number
except 1 and 83. for example if we take
here any number which is divisible by so
let's say we are taking 75 save it now
and see it says 75 is not a prime number
okay here's a spelling mistake it says
75 is a not prime number so here we'll
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically so
let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking minus 7.
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now so
it says the number is not a prime number
or if we want to try for one as well
let's take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that one
is neither a prime nor a composite
number
you can try this program with the help
of other Loops as well so let's move on
to the second problem statement but
before that let me take you through the
same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the file
Loop for the same instead of for Loop
here you can see we have used while I
less than a number by 2 and we have
given the increment condition here and
we have initialized the value of I
at the start of the program so if we try
to run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in JavaScript to
check whether a number is an Armstrong
number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program before proceeding
to the coding part let's have a look at
what is an Armstrong number so an
Armstrong number of three digits is in
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself
so for example 153 is in Armstrong
number since 1 into 1 into 1 it means
the cube of the digit 1 plus the cube of
5 that is 5 into 5 into 5 which is equal
to 125 and the cube of 3 which is three
threes are Nine and Nine threes are 27
so it will go like 125
plus 27 plus 1 so which is equal to 153
so an Armstrong number of three digits
is an integer such that the sum of the
cubes of its digits is equal to the
number itself so here we have the code
for the same this is the code to check
whether the number is an Armstrong
number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an Armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an Armstrong number next up we have
taken a variable sum and the initial
value of sum is 0. we have used the
variable sum to store the value of the
cubes and next up we have a temporary
variable so that we can break a three
digit number and we need the number
after all this all this program all
these loops and all will need the number
we'll need the original number to
compare it with the sum of the cubes
which will be hold in sum so but we need
to break the number as well right so we
need a temporary variable to break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than 0. so the initial
value of temp will be 153 here in this
particular case the initial value will
be 153 and the loop will run until the
value of 153 is greater than 0. next up
we have a variable remainder that stores
the last digits value as we are dividing
153 by 10. so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value save that variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen when we are updating the value of
sum and the MU value of sum will be 0
plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3s are Nine
and Nine threes are 27 so the updated
value of sum will be 27 next up we are
removing the last digit from the number
so for example we have here one five
three and if we divide 1 5 3 by 10 the
answer will be 1 5.3 that's why we are
using here percent because what percent
will do it will convert the float value
into an integer so if we try to perform
a simple divide in JavaScript like if we
try to divide 153 by 10 it will give us
15.3 it will give us a float value but
we want an integer value right so
percent will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be 1 5.
then again this Loop will be executed
and for this time the variable reminder
will hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5 which is 27 plus 125 right so the
new value of sum will be 152. and then
again it will go to the temp and it will
divide 15 by 10 and it will change the
value to an integer so 1.5 will be
changed to 1 and next up the final value
of temp is 1 which is greater than 0
right so it will divide 10 by 1 and the
reminder will be 1.
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10 using the percent
but this time the value will be 0
because there is no remainder right
next up we'll compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 153 is an Armstrong
number or if we use any other number
instead of 153 let's suppose we are
using 121 so it will print 121 is not an
Armstrong number let's check out the
output ones let's save it and see the
output a is one five three is an
Armstrong number so if we change the
value of 1532
one two one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an Armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the answer here will be 10 because the
cube of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8
and the cube of the final one is 1 so 8
plus 1 plus 1 is equals to 10. so that's
why one two one is not an Armstrong
number
let's move on to our last problem
statement where we'll use the do while
loop to find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number so factorial
of an integer is the product of an
integer and all the integers below it or
we can say before it till 1 so if we
take an example of 5. so the factorial
of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be 5
into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1. or if we
don't include one that's totally fine so
this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two video
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable I which is
initialized as one then we have a
variable n which is 5 and then we have a
variable F whose value is 1 F is for
factorial and n is for number we want to
check the factorial of and I is for
checking the condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where if we for example if we are taking
5 then the loop will go from 1 into 2
into 3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that
number it's not like if we are using
from 5 towards one but we are going from
1 towards five the answer will be same
right because we are multiplying all the
numbers in both the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable F and the value of f
is also one as you know so here we are
using the do while loop for the first
iteration it will perform this so the
value of f for the first iteration will
be f equals to F into I which means f
equals to 1 into 1 which is 1 so the
value of I will be increased and it will
become 2 and now it will check for while
2 is less than equals to n yes 2 is less
than n so it will again go up and it
will update the value of F and the new
value of of f will be 1 into 2 that is 2
then again the value will be increased
and it will become 3 and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of I will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5 and then it will multiply 4 with
6 because the value of f for 6 right so
4 into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of I will be 5 and it
will check if the value of I is less
than or equals to 5 right while I is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of I will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of a number so let's save this program
to the factorial of 5 is 120. because
see here we have used the factorial of
n n is 5 and the factorial is 120 so if
we try to give any other number here
other than 5 let's say we are using here
10 save it it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
or it's 36 let 28 800 so if you try to
multiply 10 into 9 into 8 into 7 so
until 2 or we can say 1 the answer will
be this you can check it you can Google
it or you can go through it in your
calculator the typical definition of
function states that to work in a proper
or in a particular way
similarly functions in JavaScript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions so a function has a particular
name and we can reuse that block of code
again and again in our entire program
for example let's suppose that we have
to add two numbers in a program that's a
basic program right sum of two numbers
so let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable X and the value
of x will be 10. then again we are going
to take a variable Y and the value of y
will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be X
Plus y
so the last thing we are going to do is
we are going to print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15. so
what is happening is
the value of x plus Y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right now
consider a scenario where we have to do
this addition for n number of times at
different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again I'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts we'll go through each of
them a function has function declaration
then it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function so let's move on and see how
the function looks like how the syntax
of function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function this is the way to write a
function next up we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the function so
this is the basic syntax of how a
function looks like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
JavaScript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming Convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out phone any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program this is happening
because we haven't called the function
yet right so to call the function we
have to write a single word just write
sum with opening and closing round
brackets and save it now now you can see
the output here is 15. so this is known
as function calling the program already
knows that there is a function by the
name sum it will go and check for the
same if the function is there or not if
the program finds it it will execute the
function next up a function can also
have parameters what do I mean by
parameters is we don't have to declare
these variables variable X and variable
y here instead of declaring them here we
can pass these values to the function
let's say we are passing X and Y here or
we can pass A and B any variable you
want to pass you can pass it here
now we can remove these variable X and
variable y we have to write here where
because we still need the variable total
and next up we have to pass the value
for these variables when we call the
function so we have to pass the values
here let's say we are passing the values
as 4 and
3.
so let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as 7.
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome to
and instead of 3 will pass simply code
right now let's save this program and
see the output it says welcome to Simply
code we don't have to worry about the
data type we'll use here because
JavaScript is a Loosely typed language
right so the function will automatically
adapt to the data type according to the
value we will pass during the function
call
here in this code
variable X holds the value welcome to
and the variable Y is having simplicode
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as parameter passing in
functions let's move on and discuss the
return types in functions so a function
can also return a value right now we can
see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there is nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and Global variable
we'll discuss this concept in upcoming
video so here you can see it says total
is not defined right so now what we have
to do is we have to write here return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to end simply code
right
so these parameters will go as X and Y
and we are getting the concatenation of
Welcome to Simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function the value of this
total variable will be given out of the
function so there has to be a particular
variable to hold the value returned by
the function
will use a variable here let's say we
are using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the LHS and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this that whenever we are
using an assignment operator the
assignment will be done from right
towards the left so whatever value the
function will return upon calling will
be assigned to the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of Simply code we'll use a
15. and we are going to print here
output on the browser because the
variable output is holding the value
returned by the function right so let's
save it now and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in JavaScript
with a quick small program that
JavaScript is a Loosely typed scripting
language right that means we don't need
to specify the data types every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in JavaScript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in JavaScript local
variables and Global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable a variable may have two
different types of scope so let's have a
look at these two different types of
variables with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable where a and the value of a will
be 5. so we have created a variable here
and let's print the value of this
variable in the browser so what we'll do
we'll print this value in the browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5. so we can
print the value of this variable anytime
and anywhere in our program right so if
we try to copy this line from here and
we'll paste it somewhere else in a
program let's say we are pasting it here
so if we try to save it now see here you
can see that we have two values of a
because we have printed a twice here
right once we have used this a here then
we have used this a here so here you can
see we have two values of a 5 and 5. so
this variable a is a global variable
which means its life is available
throughout the entire program or the
entire script we can see
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll make a function here let's say we
are creating a function
function my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where X and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
what we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable X which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now the
same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a JavaScript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for Global
variables so Global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the programs
running
or we can say until the tab is open the
next exciting thing about global
variables is that we can access Global
variables from inside the function so
what we will do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here
so now what we will do we'll declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
a variable where Y and the value of y
will be 15.
so copy this line
and paste it again now what we'll do
we'll try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15. 10 is the
value of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared X inside the function whereas
variable Y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what Global variables are one more
exciting thing I want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in JavaScript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
where one okay we have not used any
where keyword so what we are doing is we
are declaring a variable and the value
of where 1 is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the where keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function okay what we'll do
is we'll declare this variable inside
the function and we'll come in this line
and what we'll do is we'll try to access
it from outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here where one
save this
and see if you don't understand it let
me change the value of where when let's
change this value to 20 save it now and
see the output here is 10 and 20. so
where one is a variable which is
declared without using the where keyword
right so we can access this variable
from outside the function as well any
variable which is declared without using
where keyword is a global variable keep
this thing in mind guys we came across
the different types of data types
present in JavaScript in the previous
video where we came across the types of
primitive data types in JavaScript we
discussed number string and we had
Boolean null and undefined right so
these are the five types of primitive
data types present in JavaScript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where X and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have high there as the
value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and will print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable X so I
hope you guys are aware of that if you
are not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
JavaScript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable X and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right I hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and here we'll use
type of x
so let's save it and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable X so strings are
helpful for holding data that can be
represented in textual form so let's
move on to our first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in JavaScript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of HTML
tags in JavaScript right for example we
use the heading tag so often like when
we are using the document.write to print
anything on the browser we use heading
tag quite a lot right so the thing to
notice here is that these tags behaves
as HTML tags right we use them inside
the double inverted commas just like
strings but they still act like HTML
tags so let's understand this with the
help of an example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write and we'll write here hi
there and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic HTML tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the brake tag I
hope you all are aware of the brake tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we tried to
print a sentence and we are using the BR
tag right so let's print it on the
browser
so we are using the Break Tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to Simply code
so we use this Break Tag in a string
right so the output what we were
expecting was hi there and the BR should
be returning
string but there's a difference in the
output right the BR tag is actually
functioning as an HTML tag
so here the Break Tag works the same as
it did for HTML so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
HTML tag inside the JavaScript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of Escape characters present
in JavaScript
so let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we'll remove this brake tag and suppose
we want to print this on screen so we
want this on our screen and we want the
welcome to be inside the double inverted
comma in output as well so if we try to
run this program now there will be
nothing in the browser let's try to
check if it gets any error so here it
says uncut syntax error it says missing
after the argument list so how to print
this on the browser we want to highlight
the word welcome so if we try to run
this program as it is it's not working
right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash Escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma the syntax is we
have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if you want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we'll print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted command now we will
write s
the output will be it's all right
so we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
JavaScript let's save this and see if we
try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it in similar way
without using the backslash Escape
character lastly if we want to put a
backslash in our string if we want to
put a backslash we want to show it in
the browser so the Syntax for that will
go like
we have the document dot right right so
here we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes is called
backslash
so let's try to print this so here one
thing you can note is only a single
backslash is printed on the browser the
first one is used as a backslash Escape
character and second one which we have
used will be printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in JavaScript like the backslash
and or we can say new line we don't use
them quite often I'll let you know if we
use them in future so for now it's
enough for escape sequences present in
JavaScript let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars let's create a small list
here for a few different car companies
let's say we have a variable where
carbon
and the value of carbon will be let's
say
Honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say Car 2 and the value of Car 2
will be Kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3 and the value of car 3 will be
let's say food so here we have taken
three different car manufacturers we
have Honda we have Kia and we have food
and we have three different variables
right so if we want to print all three
of them what we have to do is we have to
use the document.write method right so
we have to use the document dot right
again and again so we can do it for this
small piece of code right let's print
the value of all three variables here
let's say we are using document
dot right and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was Honda we have Honda here we
have Kia and we have Ford as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right that's where arrays come into play
what we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to Define an array here first
so the Syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
We'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use Honda Kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as Honda the next one we
have is Kia
and the last one we have is
food right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have Honda we have Kia and we
have food so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of 100 car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
array so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here paste
it here and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes and now let's
save this program and see here you can
see we have all the three elements of
the array we have Honda we have Kia and
we have Ford as well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type with one single
name and can hold multiple values here
the array name is car and it stores
three similar values right here we have
three string values we have Honda Kia
and food so this array can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array so what if we want to print a
single value from these three values we
have we have Honda here and four right
so if we want to print Kia let's suppose
so it's easy to print this on a browser
all we need to know is the index number
of that value so the index number in the
case of arrays starts from 0 and goes
further so we have three values here as
we can see so the index value for these
variables will be so for Honda the index
value will be 0 and for key are the
index value will be 1 and for 4 then the
x value will be 2. so the index value
starts from 0 and goes on further so one
thing to keep in mind guys whatever
number of values and array is holding
the last index value will always be 1
less than the number of values so as
here you can see we have three values
right so the index number of the last
value will be 1 less than 3. it means
the index number will be 2 because the
index number starts from 0.
let's try to access the element present
at index 1. so we have Kia here right
all we have to do is we have to put
square brackets here in the document dot
right here we have to put square
brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of this square brackets so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have Kia only
it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
Kia
we can also Loop through this area using
the index values let's say we want to
print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here I hope you guys are aware of the
for Loop by now we'll write here so will
we have declared an array so we will use
the for Loop here and we will print here
for we'll take a variable I and the
value of I will be initial value will be
0 and then we'll give the condition the
condition will be I Less Than 3 because
we know there are three values only and
it will go till 2 only because it's
going for the index value and the final
condition will be I plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces because this is the
Syntax for for Loop and the I value will
iterate through the array and print all
the values present at indexes till the
index 2. so the same thing goes for 100
elements as well we can use the for Loop
to access all the hundred elements in
separate lines so guys if we save this
and here you can see okay
it is printing Kia Kia and Kia because
we have particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here I
and if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the I
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for Loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array we can
use the same iteration concept for doing
so so guys there's another way to
represent an array in JavaScript it goes
like this we have a let's say we have a
variable this time we'll take the
variable as very fruits so the syntax
will be like new we have to use the new
keyword and then we will use new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay and we can access the elements of
these array with the help of a for Loop
we can use the similar for Loop here so
if we copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll keep the value as I
because we want to iterate the variable
I through each index so we have once
again the index value as 0 for apple one
for banana and 2 for mango let's comment
this program as well so that it will be
easy for you guys to understand
let's save this program now and see we
have the list of all the elements
present at array fruits so we have apple
we have banana and we have mango printed
on our browser so this way of array
representation or Declaration is less
recommended because the other way which
we discussed earlier like when we
discussed the car manufacturers so that
way is a bit easier to use so I'll
recommend that way only because this way
is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys arrays in
JavaScript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like Java and C plus plus so arrays in
JavaScript have Dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime just like we saw the
string Methods in the previous video for
arrays also we have a few methods like
if we want to add elements into an array
or if we want to delete an element from
an array we have the push and pop
methods available to do such tasks
add an element into an array we use the
push method and the Syntax for pushing
elements into an array goes like so
we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array right we'll
write here the variable name dot we use
the push method and we'll push whatever
value we want to push let's say we are
adding another car manufacturer let's
say we are adding Nissan we have to
change the value here as well because
what will happen we have used the
condition I Less Than 3 so it will check
for indexes still index 2 only it won't
check for index 3. so if we write here I
less than 4 it will check for Nissan now
let's save this and see a new value is
pushed into the array which is Nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in Array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove Nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the pop option now if we use
car.pop and let's run this program and
see it says undefined this is happening
because as you can see we have pushed
the value Nissan into array so and
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular element now
if we pop out that particular element so
if we try to use cars.op once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element fold as well so let's try to
push one more value in this particular
scenario let's say we are pushing a
value as
Hyundai and now let's run this so you
can see here it have inserted Hyundai in
place of food because we have used the
pop method to put Ford out of our array
so I hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
arrays in JavaScript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in JavaScript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length properties used to find
the length of the array so if we use it
in the for Loop in place of this I less
than 4 so
here you can see we have used I less
than 4. now if we write here array dot
length so if we write here car
dot length so now we don't have to
change this value again and again so if
we are inserting any value or if we are
removing any value from this for Loop so
if we are removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is let's
say we have the length here 3 right so
it will check for the length and it will
be 1 less than the length of the array
so if we run this program now it will
work fine I hope you guys understood the
concept of array methods present in
JavaScript the other main difference
array has in JavaScript which makes it
different from C plus plus or Java is we
can add elements with other data types
in JavaScript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we'll push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push a
numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20.
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car so we can use any data type
inside array in JavaScript so let's take
a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be Audi a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from Audi is Q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car and the price
will be
let's say 50 000 US Dollars all right
next up we have a function let's say we
are using a function that is all wheel
drive
so we are having a function all-wheel
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all-wheel drive function we are using
document.write and here what we will
write
we'll write let's suppose
this car comes with Quattro all-wheel
drive Quattro I hope you guys are aware
of this word Quattro it means that four
wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here's the data about a particular
car from a particular brand Audi right
so the car model is Q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 US dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of General front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive so this
function is the behavior of the car
right it shows that the car is four
wheel drive things are pretty sorted
here right we have the data about the
car and a function associated with it so
let's save this and we can see the
output here the car comes with Quattro
all-wheel drive so this is a basic piece
of code right we have been through
functions we know how to use functions
we know how to call them so that's quite
easy for now right the problem occurs
when we have a list of cars let's say
that we have to maintain 100 different
cars with all the data of car
manufacturer we have car model price and
then we have different behaviors for
different cars not all cars have the
all-wheel drive property so what we will
do in such a case where we have to use
the same property again and again for
100 different cars or 100 different
entities we can copy paste this same
piece of code repeatedly and we have to
change the value every time we copy
paste it so we have to change the
variable name the car manufacturer the
car model and the price as well imagine
we are doing this for a list of cars
then it goes on and on so this is the
most inefficient way of tackling this
problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play these objects help us to
bundle all these properties and
attributes about one particular entity
if we talk about this particular example
of a car we can put all these properties
and many other properties like car
weight we have car color and so on
together under one name and make it an
object
let's move on to the Syntax for objects
in JavaScript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use objects now let's go
ahead and have a look at the Syntax for
objects so before we start there are few
ways in which we can create objects in
JavaScript we are going to discuss two
different ways of doing so the first one
is the literal way also known as the
literal objective
so the Syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object inside this we will
Define all the car's properties that is
whatever data we want to store about the
car like car manufacturer car model and
price in this particular scenario so
let's use them here so we have car
manufacturer and the car manufacturer is
OD
right
next up we have car model
car model is
Q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000 dollars
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all-wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the Syntax for
that will be we have to write here all
wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write a function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here so we want this
function to return this value so we'll
write here return instead of
document dot right now this function
will return this string that this cars
comes with a Quattro all-wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
use this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this so this is
what an object looks like our object is
entirely ready what we did here is we
bundled all these things and coupled
them we bundled all these things we
bundled all the three variables we
bundle this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model Etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to use document.write
so it is quite simple so after this
object we'll write here document
dot right
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the object name
with the dot operator and the property
name so if we want to Let's suppose
we'll use here car dot and property name
will be car underscore manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite easy you can see here we have used
the car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says Audi by using this dot
operator we can access any property of
the car not just a property we can
access the method as well so if we want
to access the method like if you want to
access this all-wheel drive function we
can do it simply by writing here car dot
and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write a all-wheel drive and we are
good to go so if we save this now so
here you can see it says this car comes
with four wheel drive so it is quite
easy to access these properties of an
object so we can do it by using this now
suppose we call this function normally
with the document.right inside the
function in place of return so if we
write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write a document dot
right inside this function and we can
call this function by the normal method
like if you are calling this function
from outside what we will do we'll write
a car dot and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't used any H1
tag or h2 tag so you can spot the
difference right so that's how you can
call a method of an object from outside
this is the normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture in which we use something
different known as object Constructor
that's a bit different from other object
oriented programming languages so don't
worry if you don't know about it also in
the newer versions JavaScript supports
the concept of classes and object so
what we used to say earlier is
Javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed JavaScript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference so
we'll comment this that's why we are not
removing it but we can remove this piece
of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object now we will create multiple
objects using a single template which is
known as a Constructor function
let's have a look at the Syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only now
inside a function these parameters are
known as arguments so if we talk about
the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically so
what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
Constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values so all these values will
be present at the rhs so let me write
this first let's say we are using this
Dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will right here car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and Method as well so let's
use the other two properties which were
this Dot car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this Dot price
right here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the Constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this we'll use this
dot all-wheel drive
and this is a function so we will write
here function with the opening and
closing round brackets and then we have
the body of the function inside the body
of this function we will write whatever
we have written in the previous program
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it here
right so this is a complete Constructor
function Now using this Constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this Constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
C plus plus and Java so let's create an
object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable C1 now
we'll use the new keyword and along with
the
Constructor function so we'll use your
cards and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have the car manufacturer is Audi and
next up we have the
model as
Q7 and the prices
50 000. okay so we have created a
variable we have passed the values for
the properties and now if you want to
access this function if we want to
access this all-wheel drive function we
can access this as well we have to write
here C1 dot all-wheel drive and this is
how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here H2 Tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where C2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cards and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
BMW
and next up we have the model as
X7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 USD so if we want to
access any particular property of any
object like if we want to access the car
model or if we want to access the car
manufacturer so we can do it the same
way as we did previously as we did in
the literal object way so
to do so we have to write a
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name Dot and
whatever we want to print let's say we
are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here X7 is
printed on the browser because X7 is the
value of object C2 and let's suppose if
we want to
Frontier car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have BMW as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000 so this
is how we can create multiple objects in
JavaScript we'll continue with the
previous program we made so today we
will use the literal object way because
this method of creating objects is a bit
easier than the other one we discussed
which was the Constructor function
method so here we created the car object
which has three properties car
manufacturer car model and the price of
the car we have a method here as
all-wheel drive when we use this method
here we use this method with the dot
operator and we called that function we
call that method with the help of the
object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video if we talk
about objects in JavaScript a lot of
things we know about in JavaScript are
basically objects like the Boolean
values numbers strings and a few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we Define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we Define
them with the new keyword so we have a
few predefined objects as well we have
the math object the date object and the
regular expression are also considered
objects in JavaScript a lot of things
are objects in JavaScript we'll use
objects in Dom manipulation which we
will go through in further videos so
that's why it is pretty essential to
understand the whole concept of objects
right so next next up let's look at how
we can use different data types as
objects in JavaScript
so the Syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in JavaScript goes like
this we will declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so Stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in JavaScript if
we'll write here
str1 and we'll use the dot operator so
here we can see we have the object
methods as well right so I hope you guys
are aware of the methods present in
JavaScript like we had the string and
array methods right we have methods for
object as well like the index of method
we have seen the use of index of method
when we went through the string Methods
in JavaScript so similarly we have the
font color and the length property for
object as well so length here is the
property and other which we can see are
the methods for objects in JavaScript so
here this str1 becomes the object by
default when we use the new keyword with
the string while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type so the easiest way to do so is to
use the type of operator so let's use it
here and check the type of variable str1
we'll write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the H1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we write here any
string let's suppose we are using a
string here let's say we are using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a Stringer layer but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string and this is the basic syntax
of how to define a primitive data type
as an object so if we save it now here
you can see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and the other
predefined objects we talked about like
the date object and the math object
we'll go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can say we have written here
150 line of codes so
I'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in JavaScript we can add a particular
property to an object outside the
definition also we can add a property to
an object anywhere in a program the
Syntax for that goes like this will
write the object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say black right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we'll write here
document dot right
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on your browser so we have used a
car.car color let's save this program
now and see here you can see the output
is black so this is the property of the
object car now and if we comment this
line let's say if we are commenting this
line let's save this now and see here
you can see it says undefined we can add
more properties similarly like if we
want to add another property here we can
go like car dot and the property name
whatever property we want to add let's
say we want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll see it will go like
car dot let's say we are adding a new
function
let's say we are adding the function new
fun equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
edit
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so I hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object so it's pretty easy to
do so in JavaScript we can use the
delete keyword object name and the
property name after the dot operator
let's suppose we want to delete car
model here we want to delete this
particular property of the object car so
we what we'll do we'll delete this car
model so the Syntax for it is quite
simple so we'll remove this for now and
we'll delete a property let's say we are
using the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here car
model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so we'll write here
car dot current score model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is Q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know JavaScript is a Loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write so we
have to write here car dot
price
and update the value here let's say we
are using 70 000 and we have to put a
semicolon it's the same thing we do to
update the value of a particular
variable right so if we try to print the
value of price now we'll get the output
as 70 000. let's try to print it on the
browser so we'll cut it from here we'll
paste it here and we'll print car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property what we can do is we can use
the type of operator so we'll use the
type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string earlier it
was a number but now it is a string so
all these things can be done dynamically
in a program wherever we want to do them
so that's the benefit of having objects
in JavaScript today we are going to take
input from the user with the help of a
text box in JavaScript what we'll do is
we'll create a text box and any value
the user will write inside the text box
will be stored in a variable and then we
will print that variable in a message
using the alert method or in the control
so whatever we want to do we can do it
so let's create a small login page with
no styling because we'll be focusing
more on the HTML and the JavaScript
parts so for that we have to go to our
HTML file so here's our HTML file and
we'll write here
input
and then we'll write a type is equals to
name and then we'll write here
placeholder is equals to let's say enter
name this placeholder is an attribute
that gives a slight hint whatever value
we write here will be printed inside the
box so this enter name will be printed
inside this particular text box
so save it and here you can see on the
browser we have a text box here here you
can see how this value is written inside
the text box you can see here enter name
is written inside a text box indicating
the user to write the name here so let's
create another text block here for the
password we are creating a login page
right so we'll be needing name and
password so we'll use the BR tag here
and then we'll write here
input type is equals to
password
and then we'll
use a placeholder here and we'll write
here
enter
password this type attribute here plays
a vital role on this input element
because we have different types of
values we can use inside a text box like
we have numbers strings week time email
password and many more so here we are
using password
so save it and you can see here we have
two text boxes over here in the browser
so we have a text box for name and we
have a text box for password
next up we need a button to perform a
task right so we'll use the on click
method along with this button we can
either use the button tag or we can use
the input tag along with type is equals
to button so we'll write here input
type is equals to button and the value
will be
say submit
or we can write here login essay save it
and here you can see we have a button
over here named as submit so we are done
with the login setup here we have a text
box for the name and one for the
password so we'll write any name here
you can see let's write here question
and then we'll write the password here
let's say any random password and
nothing will happen if we click on the
submit button so let's add some
functionality to this submit button here
so we'll go back to HTML file and we'll
write here
on click so we'll write here a function
name
print fine
we'll create this print function now so
we'll go to our JavaScript file and
we'll create a function here so let's
say function name is print and then we
have the body of the function now this
function will be called whenever we
click on this button so whenever we
click on the submit button this print
function will be called now we want this
button to do something right we want it
to perform a certain task what we want
to do is we want the user to write their
name and password and we will print this
name and password in the pop-up with the
help of alert method so we'll use the
document.getelement by ID method for
this task let's give those elements
their IDs so we'll give these two input
tags their IDs so we'll write here
ID is equals to let's say you name or
username and then we have the password
for password we'll give the ID as you
pass fine save it and then we'll go back
to our JavaScript file now both these
elements have their own IDs we'll use
them in the Javascript file so we want
to use the values given by the user
right for that we'll create two
variables here inside the function print
to hold the reference of original value
so for that we'll write here where X is
equals to
document dot get element by ID and then
we have the IDS you name for the
username and then we'll write here dot
when next up we'll take another variable
let's say where Y and then we'll write
here
document dot get element by ID again
then we have the IDS
U pass
we'll write here dot value now what we
did here is we use the IDS to get the
reference of those values which the user
will input you might have noticed here
that we have used the value property
here after the IDS so this value
property Returns the value attribute of
any text box
so now we have the values here present
inside variables X and variable y the
next thing we want to do is we want to
print these values right so for that
we'll use the alert method so it's quite
easy to use we'll write here alert and
then we'll write here
the name is and then we'll print
X so because variable X is holding the
value of name then we'll
use slash n and after that we'll write
here
the password is and then we'll print the
value of Awesome
so we are done with it we have printed
the values of X and Y here now save it
and now we'll enter the values here
let's say the name is
caution and the password is Simply Good
the moment we click on this submit
button there will be a pop-up with a
message you can see it here the name is
kaushal and the password is simply code
we printed these variables here along
with the alert method
so this is how we can take input from
the user in JavaScript so we already
discussed that we want to create a login
form here with a specific name or
password right let's say we want the
user to be allowed only if the password
is simply cool otherwise the user should
be restricted from entering the web page
so this is a simple task all we have to
do here is we have to use the if else
control statements so for that we'll
write here after this statement we'll
write here if and then we'll write here
let's say pass we are doing it for
password right so we'll write a y is
equal to is equals to
simply code then we have the body of if
we'll write here alert
login successfully
and then we'll write here else this the
statement will be
alert
wrong password
so we'll keep this line here so what
will happen is the moment we'll press
the submit button it will go to the FL
statement and it will check if the
password entered by the user matches the
correct password or not so if the
password matches it will print login
successful otherwise it will print the
wrong password and then finally it will
print the name entered by the user and
the password as well so let's save it
and we'll write here the name as let's
say caution
and the password let's say the password
will be different this time we'll write
a simply learn
so this password does not matches the
original password right the original
password is simply code so what we are
expecting is it will return wrong
password here so let's save it the
moment we press the submit button you
can see here we have a pop-up with
message wrong password because the
password we entered is simply learn so
if we press OK here in the next message
you can see the name is kosher and the
password is simply fine so let's do it
again this time we'll enter the correct
password we'll write here simply code
and we'll change the name as well so
let's say the name is
Rahul
submit it and here you can see we have
the message as login successful
we will press OK and here you can see
the name is Rahul and the password is
simply cool in this tutorial we will see
how we can use radio buttons to take
input from users now HTML radio buttons
are created with the help of input text
and the type for creating radio buttons
is Radio we can use radio buttons on
multiple occasions for example we can
create a quiz question using a radio
button at one time only a single radio
button will be selected and we can use
it to find the correct answer so today
we will use radio buttons along with the
ID attribute and then we will create a
JavaScript function to find the correct
answer for a quiz so without wasting any
time let's move on to the programming
part
so first we will see how to add radio
buttons to our HTML document
in the HTML file we will write here
input
type is equals to radio
and then we have
value is equals to let's say option one
because we are using multiple options
right we have multiple options for a
single question or we have multiple
options here so we'll write value as
option one and then we'll write here the
value we want to print so we'll write
your option
one
fine save it and we have a radio button
over here you can see we can check it
and it has no functionality till now
so let's add another button first so
what we'll do we'll copy this line from
here and
we'll paste it and then we'll change the
option as option 2 and the value also as
option two
right save it again and here you can see
we have two radio buttons now let's add
a submit button here first so we'll
right here
input type is equals to
button and then we have value is equal
to submit save it and here you can see
we have a submit Button as well one
thing you might notice here is we can
check both the text boxes right we can
check option 1 and option 2 both at the
same time so if we want to select only
one checkbox at a time we have to group
them so we'll use the name attribute and
the same name for these two radio
buttons so the name will remain the same
for both of these
radio buttons so we'll write a name is
equals to let's say
G1 and then we'll write here as well
we'll write here name is equals to G1
now these two radio buttons belong to
the same group
save it and now if you try to check both
these boxes you can see we can't do it
now because we have grouped them and now
we can select only one radio button at a
time right
now the next thing we are going to do is
we'll move to a JavaScript file and
we'll create a function there so we'll
move to a Javascript file so here's our
Javascript file and we'll create a
function here so let's do it first so
we'll write here
function
let's say the function name is
fun one fine and then we have the body
of this function so inside this function
we'll write here we'll take two
variables again for both the elements so
we'll write here where X and then we'll
write a document Dot
get element by ID then we'll write here
the ID
so let's provide the ID to those
elements as well so we'll write here
uh before name will provide the ID so
let's say the ID for the first radio
button is red one and the ID for the
second one will be
let's say Red Two Fine save
and we'll go back to our Javascript file
we'll write here red one
and then we'll take another variable
we'll write here where Y is equals to
document dot get element by ID method
and then we'll write here the ID so the
ID for the second radio button is
red two fine we don't need the value
property here next up we have to use the
if else statement to print something
right so we'll write here we'll use the
if else statement we'll write if
and then we have
x dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return something right so
we have a condition here as if x dot
checked is equal to is equals to true
this particular statement will check if
the radio button whose reference is
available at variable X is selected or
not this dot checked is the property for
a HTML element if the radio button is
checked the output will be something so
let's add the output here as well so the
output will be if the radio button is
checked
will be like we'll write a alert then
we'll write here the
option
selected
is
then we will write here
x dot
value so it will print the value of x as
well
now we have another condition here
we'll write here if y dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return the options
selected is we'll write here plus y dot
value we are doing this because we have
three different conditions here right if
we select option one or if we select
option two or if we are not selecting
any of these options right so we have a
else condition for that and then we'll
write here else so here we have to write
else if
and then we'll write here else
and else part will print
alert no option
selected save it and let's do one thing
first we'll call this function with the
help of on click method so we'll go back
to HTML file and we'll write here in
this element we'll write here on click
and we'll call this function on click
so we'll write your fun one and we have
this function here save it and here we
are good to go
so if we move back to our JavaScript
file you can see here we have three
conditions either X is checked or Y is
checked or none of these are checked so
let's
check the output now we'll select Option
1 first we'll submit it and here you can
see we have the output as the option
selected is option one fine press ok
then we'll refresh this page and we'll
select option 2 and now we'll press the
submit button so here you can see on
selecting option two we have the output
here as the option selected is option
two right so what if we are not
selecting any of these two radio buttons
so
click the submit button here and you can
see we have the output as no option
selected so I hope you guys got it now
the syntax will remain the same if we
want to create a quiz so next up what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a quiz
so here is the code if you want to
create a quiz on your own so we have a
question here we have a question as
JavaScript was developed in the year and
then we have two options for it we have
1998 as first option so if we go here
you can see we have the first option is
1998 and then we have another option is
1995. obviously we know the answer for
it as 1995 will change the function name
here as
fun one and save it the Javascript file
for this code will look like this so we
have three conditions here again if x is
checked then the output will be wrong
answer and the correct answer is y and
then we have another condition for y if
Y is checked or we can say if 1995 is
checked will have the output as right
answer and then we have another
condition if none of these radio buttons
are checked we have the output as no
option selected so let's see if the code
works fine so save it and we'll go to
the browser so we'll select option one
first so we'll select this 1998 submit
it and here you can see we have the
output as wrong answer the correct
answer is 1995 right we have the value
of y here the value variable Y is
holding is 1995 so we printed it over
here and we have the output as y dot
value which is 1990
so if we refresh it and if we select
1995 here then we'll press the submit
button and here you can see we have the
output as right answer fine press OK and
we are going to do it again so this time
we won't be selecting any of these
options we'll just click on the submit
button and we have the output as no
option selected fine I hope you guys
understood it in the last few videos we
discussed the same thing right we saw
how we could take input using text boxes
and then we saw how we can take input
using radio buttons today we are going
to grab users input with the help of a
select box in JavaScript so without
wasting any time let's move on to the
programming part directly first we'll
see how to create a select box in HTML
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part so let's move on to HTML and we'll
create a select box here if you guys
remember we use the input tag in the
previous few videos for text boxes and
radio buttons but for the select box the
scenario is a bit different we have to
use the select element in HTML so we'll
write here
select
so we have the select element here we
have to use this for select box in
JavaScript or in HTML
so this select box is used to create
drop down list of some elements so we
can add as many elements as we want to
that list so we'll use the option tag
for each component we are going to use
so the code goes like this will
start with the select tag and let's save
this and see if it makes any changes to
a browser so you can see it on the
browser that we have a button over here
now we'll add options to this drop down
list for that we'll use the option tag
we'll write here option
and let's say we have three options we
have three car manufacturers name so
let's say the first name is BMW then
we'll copy this
statement and
we'll paste it again and again and then
we'll change the name of Manufacturers
so let's say another manufacturer is
Audi and the last one is food fine we
have three manufacturers now save it and
you can see it over here we have a drop
down list of three different elements we
have BMW or dn4 here next up we'll add a
button so a submit Button as we did in
the previous few videos for that we will
write here input type is equals to
button and then we have value
is equals to
submit fine
save it and we'll use a br tag here
save it now and here you can see we have
a drop down list here we have a select
box here and then we have a submit
button over here
fine
now we want to print the option we
selected by clicking this submit button
for that we have to add functionality to
our HTML document right so we'll follow
the same steps as we did in the last
video wherein we used the radio buttons
and the text boxes so we'll write here
inside this input tag we'll write here
on click so what we want to do is we
want to call a function on clicking a
submit button right so we will write
here a function name so let's say the
function name is selected
and we have to use the ID attribute in
the select element right so we'll use
the ID attribute here we are not going
to use our ID attribute inside the
option text but we are going to use the
ID attribute inside the select text we
will write here ID
is equals to let's say
1. fine
so we have an ID here now we have to use
the value property here as well so I
hope you guys remember the value
property which we discussed in previous
videos so the value property is used to
access these values right so we'll write
here
value is equals to
BMW and then for Audi the value will be
OD and then for Ford the value will be
food fine save it and here we are done
with the HTML document so next up we'll
create a function in the Javascript file
so let's move on to the Javascript file
and we'll create a function over here
so we'll write here
function and the function name is
selected
then we have the body of this function
right so we are going to repeat the same
steps we are going to take a variable X
which will hold the reference of Select
statement so we'll write here
document Dot
get element by ID and then we'll write
here the ID so the ID is one
so now we have a variable X which holds
the reference value of Select element
right
now we have used the
document.getelementbyid method to get
the reference of the selected value next
up we'll use some properties for select
element while printing the value with
alert method so if you guys remember in
the previous video wherein we use the
dot checked property for radio buttons
so similarly we have some more
properties here for the select boxes as
well so let's have a look at them
so we'll write here
alert
and then we have a property which will
go like this we'll write here x dot
options
and then we have
this brackets and Dot value
so this options property here is a
collection of all the options we have in
our select tag
we have multiple options right this
property works on arrays so we have an
array of all the elements and we can
access any of them for that we will
write here the index value right so
let's say the index value is 0 we want
to print the element present at number
one so we'll save it and the moment we
press submit button you can see here we
have the output as BMW now one thing to
notice here is
it doesn't matter which option the user
chooses the output will remain BMW for
all those cases because we are using the
first element of the array so no matter
which option the user is selecting the
message will be there with the value
present at index 0.
so we can say now that we can't use
static values right we can't use 0 1 or
2 here because we want
to provide the value dynamically because
we have three different values here and
we want to print the value which the
user selected not the one present at
index is 0 1 or 2. so for that we have
another property here we have to write a
x dot
select
did index
and one thing you have to remember is we
have to write here x dot selected index
or any variable we are using here so we
are good to go now save it and if we
press submit now while
clicking on BMW so our first option is
BMW let's press the submit button and
here you can see we have the output as
BMW
and next up we'll be selecting OD and
we'll press submit so here you can see
we have the output as already now
and finally we have forward as well so
let's check it as well so press the
submit button and here you can see we
have the output is food
so this is how we can take inputs in
JavaScript from drop down lists next up
we'll go through a simple program as we
did in the last video wherein we'll
Create a quiz question and we'll check
if the option selected by the user is
correct or not so this is the code for
that so we have the question here is
Javascript was developed by we are using
another question different from the one
we used in the last video so we know who
developed JavaScript right so we have a
question here JavaScript was developed
by and then we have two options for the
same question the first one is Brendan
Ike and the second one is guidoven
Rossum
so then we have the ideas one for the
select element and the values are also
the same then we have a button over here
which will call function one on clicking
and if we move to a Javascript file we
can see here we have a function fun one
and then we have a variable X which
holds the reference of value
returned by document.getelement by ID
method and then we use this value so we
have used a x dot option so what we are
doing is we are basically checking that
if the selected value is equals to
Brendan Ike or not if the value is equal
to Brandon I then the output will be the
answer is correct else the output will
be the answer is wrong so let's save it
and we'll move back to HTML file and
we'll save this file as well so now here
you can see we have a question over here
and we have a select box which has two
options Brendan I can guide you and
Rossum right so let's select Brendan Ike
first press the submit button and here
you can see it says the answer is
correct fine next up we are going to use
gaido and Rossum and we are going to
press submit button so here you can see
the answer is wrong
we have been using the
document.getelement by ID method for the
past few videos right we know it is used
to access an HTML element with the help
of an ID which is uniquely provided to
each element
so we used that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then with
select boxes as well so today we are
going to use a method that is somewhat
similar to document.getelement by ID
method
so we'll be using the
document.getelements by tag name method
in JavaScript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
tags style we can do it with the help of
this method so we'll look at the syntax
first and then we'll move on to the
difference between ID and tag name
method so let's move on to the
programming part directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use CSS for that but in JavaScript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are writing it
this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part
so we'll write here let's use the BR tag
and we'll write here input tag again
we'll write a input type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click and
let's say our function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button so next up what we are
going to do is we are going to add
functionality to the submit button for
that we have to move to our Javascript
file and we have to create a function
over there
so we'll write here in the Javascript
file we'll write here
function
and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelement by ID method what
we'll do here is we'll take a variable X
and then we'll write here
document Dot
get Elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so in
this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in an HTML document we can
access paragraph tags we can access
anchor text and any tag we want to
basically
so save it and here now we have a
variable X that holds an HTML collection
of all the div text present inside the
HTML file this means that we have an
array of references of all the div tags
here inside this variable X
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
Index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of HTML document because
we know arrays start from 0 and at 0 the
first element will be present so this
div tag will be present at number 0. and
then we are going to use this style
property so we know that X here is not a
variable only actually X here acts as an
object and we know that different
objects have certain properties in
JavaScript so style is one of those
properties and next up we'll write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the CSS part with properties
present in JavaScript so let's say we
are changing our font to
Courier new
fine so this is a font name and we can
use any font name over here so save it
what will happen now is on clicking the
submit button the font of this
particular section the font of div 1
will change to Korean so let's try if
it's happening or not on clicking the
submit button you can see over here the
change between this line and other three
div tags clearly the font has changed
the new font is Courier new and what we
did here is we changed the font family
of this particular Dev tag so similarly
we can make more styling changes to
other div tags as well so let's do it
here
and we'll
make changes to each of the dev tags we
have in a HTML file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and index number will be 2.
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing here
font style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for x
for the uh repeats so let's say for the
last div tag we are using the background
color
fine and we'll write here the color name
is
red so we are good to go now save it and
we have four different properties over
here for section four we are changing
the
background color so three will be the
index number of the last array variable
so save it and on pressing the submit
button you can see the change over here
so for section one the font is changed
to Courier new for section two the font
color is blue let me Zoom it out a bit
to show you guys you can see over here
the color is blue and then we have
italic text in section three and finally
for section 4 we have the background
color as four right
so you can see how we are accessing any
particular element of the array now why
we are using these properties separately
for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in JavaScript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable X is holding an array of all
the div text present in a HTML file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
Elements by tag name method to overcome
this problem we have a solution as well
so the solution for this problem is we
have to use the for Loop View so how
this for Loop works so we'll write here
and then we'll take a local variable I
and the initial value will be 0. then
we'll write a i
less than x dot length because we want
to Traverse the whole array right and
then we'll write here the condition I
plus plus so we are going to go then we
have this body of for Loop and inside
here we'll write X and the index number
will be I because it will keep on
changing and we are in a loop so we'll
write here dot style and then let's say
the style we want to do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font Boulder fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me Zoom this and if we
click on this submit button you can see
the font is more bold right so if we are
using another property here let's say
the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div text for all the
four section is changed to Yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once now what we
did is we started a loop and traversed
every element in the array and applied
the same property to each element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of tag name method in JavaScript
now what if we have hundreds of similar
elements like div tag present in our
website and all of them are present at
different locations so let's try to do
it and what we'll do is we'll insert
certain different elements in between
these div tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted two
three more elements in between these div
tags so save it and you can see after
each section we have something else here
we have a form with two different text
boxes we have name and age and then we
have a submit Button as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two then after
section two we have radio button and the
value is a then we have another radio
button B and in between we have all the
dev text present so basically what we
want to do is we want to change the
style for each of the div tags right so
we will change the background color here
so let's say we'll write here red and
what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section one
two three and four will change to red so
let's try to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as red so this is
working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of ID attribute for each element
so we are saying this for a long time
that the ID for each element should be
unique wise although we saw in the past
videos that we can use the same ID for
two different elements when we did the
same for accessing a CSS styling
property using the ID attribute but if
we try to do the same thing with
JavaScript we'll get an error for
example if we try to access the value of
any particular element with the ID
attribute but we have two elements in a
HTML file with the same ID so it will
throw an error in that case basically
and this is the reason why we use the
tag name method in JavaScript so that if
we want to access multiple elements of
the same name we can do it with this
method because it's not possible to use
the ID method separately for each
element present in the HTML document
right because we have certain same HTML
tags present within an HTML document
like we have the div tags here similarly
a website is long enough to have
multiple similar elements present within
it so that's why we use the
document.getelements by tag name method
in JavaScript so guys in the past few
videos we use two different methods of
accessing an element from an HTML file
using JavaScript properties so we know
the difference between the ID method and
the tag name method right today we will
use another method to access a
particular element in JavaScript that is
the class name method or we can say the
get Elements by class name method in
JavaScript so before discussing the
class name method in JavaScript let's
look at why accessing an element is
important in JavaScript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change add or delete
HTML elements we saw earlier that we
could change HTML elements or the CSS
style of any element in the document
with the help of JavaScript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the ID method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in JavaScript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the ID attribute used in HTML we
know that ID has to be unique for each
element but we know that many elements
in an HTML document can have the same
class right so we used Class to access
specific CSS properties in the previous
videos and that is the only benefit of
using classes in JavaScript so we can
say that a single class can be used by
many elements within an HTML document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so will write here in the
HTML file we'll add five different
elements so let's say we are writing
here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
Section 1 we'll copy this
will paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
P tag we'll write this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four in
five so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph tags in
between the div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in a HTML
document three of them are the div text
section one two and five are div text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph text so now let's suppose we
want to change the style of three of
these elements let's say one four and
five so we can do it in two ways right
either we can use the ID method or we
can use the class method however we can
use the tag name method as well but we
have to use two different variables for
that right that will be a lengthy
process why two different variables
because we have two different tags
present here right we have to create
separate variable for the div tag and
separate one for the paragraph tag so
that will be a lengthy process so we'll
consider ID method and the class name
method for here so considering the ID
method the document.getelement by ID
method we have to provide unique ID to
each element so we have to provide
unique ID to this div tag then we have
to provide to each and every element
here right so because we need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the ID to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an HTML file so we'll use
the class attribute in each element we
want to access
so let's say we want to access section
one two and five so we'll write a class
let's say the class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing 1 2 and 4 because 1 2 and 5
are the div text so we can access these
with the help of tag name method as well
so we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here next up we'll create a button and
then we'll add functionality to a HTML
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it and here you can see in the
browser we have five sections over here
we have section one two three four and
five then we have a submit button which
will call the function on clicking so we
haven't added functionality till now so
let's move ahead to our Javascript file
and we'll add functionality to a
HTML document
so inside this JavaScript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
funkmon then we have the body of this
function so the syntax remains a bit
same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
HTML file
so we'll write here
where X is equals to
document Dot
get Elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
X in the form of an HTML collection so
now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section one that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0. then we'll write Dot
tile
and this style is a property dot then
let's say we want
to change the font style so we'll write
here
font style
font style will be
italic save it so this piece of code
will change the font style of the
element present at index 0. save it and
on clicking the submit button here on
the browser we can see the change in
this section right so if it's not
visible so let me Zoom it a bit for you
here you can see guys the font at
Section 1 is changed to italic right so
in this case we have all the three
elements present in a array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index one now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it 2 and we'll write here 1.
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we'll change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bold
so we'll write here Boulder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the font readers Bolder so you can see
the change over here so this is how we
can make change to each element
separately and we can also make changes
in all the elements at once as well so
for that we have to use the for Loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right so for that we'll write here so
let's come in these three statements
first
and then we'll write here
four and
we'll take a local variable here we'll
write you where I is equals to 0 I will
start from index 0 and I will go till
x dot length
and then we have the condition as I plus
plus
so inside the body of for Loop we'll
write here X and
instead of index number we'll write here
I because we want to Traverse the whole
array then we'll write Here style Dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for Loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on a browser the
background color for all the three
sections that is one two and four is
changed to Yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelements by class name
method to access all the elements
present in an HTML file with a
particular class next up let's discuss
the difference between the ID method tag
name method and the class name method so
we'll discuss when to use which method
so let's start with the ID method so the
ID method is used when we want to access
a single element and we have to provide
a unique ID to that element in order to
access it so the ID method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods we can either use the class name
method or the tag name method for more
than one element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name we can access all
the similar tags present within an HTML
document with the help of tag name
method the only problem is we can access
similar types of tags only at one time
we can't access two different types of
tags with this method so this is where
the class name method comes into play we
can access more than one element with
this method and the elements can be
different just like we did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so the
section 1 2 and 5 are from devtax and
the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
JavaScript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the HTML file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so by now I hope you guys
understood the concept of all the three
methods which we have discussed the ID
method the tag name method and the class
name method in JavaScript we can use any
of these methods according to our needs
so guys we have been discussing specific
methods of accessing an element for the
past few videos now today we are going
to discuss something different before
going deep into this topic let's recall
events in JavaScript so the simple
definition of an event states that
something that happens so when we
manipulate an HTML document in
JavaScript we try to do something on the
web page right so several events take
place on a website like the user hovers
over a specific element or clicks on an
element or pressing a key in the website
can also refer to events or we can say
submitting a form or playing a video
also refers to the same thing so we are
using the on click event for the past
few videos wherein we discuss that a
specific task would be performed on
clicking a particular button what we did
was we were just calling a function by
clicking a button in HTML so clicking a
button is also an event right and the
function that will be called upon
clicking the button is known as event
handler because that function is
basically asking the computer to perform
a particular task on clicking the button
so like the on click event we have some
more exciting events present in HTML
which helps us make a web page more
interactive and responsive as well so we
can do it with the help of JavaScript so
we'll go through two such events today
the on Mouse over event and the on Mouse
out event so the on Mouse over event
will perform a task when the user takes
the mouse cursor on that element
similarly the on Mouse out event also
performs a task when the user takes the
mouse cursor away from that element so
for example let's suppose we have an
image present in our web page and we
want to change the size of that image
when the user takes the mouse cursor
over that image and the image should get
back to its previous size when the user
takes away the crystal so what's
basically happening is when the user is
taking its Mouse over the image or
picture the picture size will increase
and on taking the mouse cursor away from
the image the size will get back to its
default size so let's do it once and
we'll see how these events work within
an HTML document so first of all let's
add an image to the HTML file we'll use
the IMG tag for that and we'll have to
provide the path for the image right so
we'll write here in a HTML file We'll
add an image here so we'll write here
IMG and then we have to provide the
source and the images are stored inside
the images folder in this system so
we'll write here the image name so we
have provided the path here next up what
we'll do is we'll use the alt attribute
so we'll write here in the alt we'll
write a simply code
fine
save it
and here you can see we have an image
over a browser but the image size is
quite large right so we'll limit the
size of this image using the width
property so what we'll do is we'll write
here width
and let's say the width of the image
will be 250 pixel
save it and now you can see we have an
image over here the image is in its
normal size so this is the image so we
have this image over here and next thing
what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the size of this picture on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
so what will happen is when we take our
mouse cursor here the picture size will
increase so for that we have to use the
on Mouse over property or we can see the
on Mouse over event so what we'll do is
we'll write here on Mouse
over and we'll call a function on taking
the mouse cursor over this image so
we'll write here change size
so we will declare it in a JavaScript
file and we'll call this function on
taking the mouse cursor over this
picture
so next thing we are going to do is
we are going to move to our JavaScript
file and we'll Define this change size
function there
so let's
go to the JavaScript part we'll go to a
JS file and we'll write here we'll
declare a function first so we'll write
here function change size
and then we have the body of this
function so we can do it without taking
any variable like in the previous videos
we were taking a variable to store the
reference of the ID attribute so this
time we are going to use the
document.getelement by ID but we are not
going to use a separate variable for
storing the reference so we'll write
here
document dot get element by ID and we
haven't provided the ID yet so let's do
one thing let's move back to a HTML file
and we'll use the ID attribute here as
well inside the IMG tag we'll write a ID
let's say the ID is
I am June I mean save it and we'll
write here inside the JS file will give
the ID here as well so we have the IDS
IMG one
save it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the style
property with this document.getelement
by ID method so we'll write here Dot
style and then we'll write a DOT width
and then we'll specify the width so
we'll write here the width as let's say
500 pixel the default width is
250 pixels right so save it and let's
see if it's working fine or not so here
is the image on the browser and we'll
take the mouse cursor over the image and
you can see the change in the size of
this picture so JavaScript makes it easy
to do such tasks now you might have
noticed that the image's size Remains
the Same once the user takes the mouse
cursor away from the image right so the
image size is changed let me zoom out a
little bit so it will be easy for you
guys so what we'll do is we'll refresh
this page and here you can see on taking
the mouse cursor over this image the
change in the size of this particular
picture
so now the image size is 500 pixel now
the image size is not getting back to
its original size like what we did was
we use the on Mouse over event and the
image size is changing and that's
working totally fine so the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
use the on Mouse out event and what will
happen is the image size will get back
to its default size like which is the
250 pixel so we'll for that we'll use
another function so first we have to use
the on Mouse out event here
so we'll write here on Mouse out and we
have to create another function so we'll
write a change size 2 so this will be a
function name save it
and here we have to create another
function in the JavaScript file so we'll
write here function change size and the
function name is change size to then we
have the body of this function and we'll
use the document Dot
get element by ID method
the ID is same which is IMG one and then
we are going to use the style property
again and this time we'll specify the
width as
250 pixel so this is the default size of
our image save it so what we did is we
created a function that will be called
when the user takes away the mouse
cursor from the picture and the image
size will be changed to 250 pixels which
was the initial size of the image
so save it
and now you can see here on the browser
the image size is changing on taking the
mouse cursor over the image the image
size is 500 pixel now and on taking the
mouse cursor away from the image the
image is getting back to its default
size right so you can see the change
here so this is how we can use these
events to make a web page more
interactive and attractive as well next
up we'll go through another example
wherein we will change the image on the
mouse over event and the default image
will be shown on taking the cursor away
from the image so this image will change
on taking the mouse cursor over it and
again it will get back to the default
image on taking the mouse cursor away
from the image so guys here's the code
for the same and what will happen is the
image will change on taking the mouse
cursor over it and gets back to the
default on taking the cursor away so
guys the HTML part will remain the same
wherein we use the IMG tag to add an
image and then we have two functions one
for the on Mouse over and another for
the on Mouse out event so in the
JavaScript file we defined the two
functions here so you can see the
function one is change image and the
function 2 is change image 2. so what's
happening is we are using the get
element by ID method again and this time
we are using the SRC attribute and what
we are doing is we are changing the
source of image like we are using here
the simply learn.png so this is our
image saved in the particular folder
inside the images folder and in the next
function what we are doing is we are
again changing the image to the default
image so we have used the simply
code.png image here so what will happen
is the default image will be replaced by
this image when this function is called
and the other function here will again
replace the new image with the default
one so let's take a look at the output
and save it so here you can see on
taking mouse cursor over this image you
can see the change so this is the image
we want to change so on taking the Mouse
cuts are away from this image you can
see the image gets back to the default
one you can see the image is changing
and it's quite responsive and attractive
guys inheritance is an essential Concept
in any object-oriented programming
language inheritance refers to the
procedure through which one class or one
Constructor inherits the properties and
methods of another Constructor in simple
terms let's suppose we have a
Constructor named as vehicle and we know
we have different types of vehicles
present like we have cars and we have
bikes as well so all these types share a
few things in common right now if we
want to create a Constructor let's say
we want to create a Constructor bike and
we want it to have a few of the same
properties and methods as of the
vehicles Constructor
so in that case we are left with two
options
either we can copy the properties from
vehicle Constructor and paste them
inside the bike Constructor or we can
simply use inheritance to inherit those
properties from the vehicle Constructor
to the bike Constructor in this case the
vehicle class will be known as a base
class and the bike Constructor or class
will be known as derived Constructor
because we derived a few properties from
the vehicle Constructor right
don't worry guys I know the concept of
classes might be new for you and the
concept of inheritance might seem a bit
different from other languages like if
you are coming from a C plus plus
background you may notice that there we
use classes for the concept of
inheritance but in JavaScript before the
introduction of es6 that is ecmascript
6. the concept of inheritance was based
on Constructors and prototypes so with
the introduction of ecmascript 6 the
idea of classes was also introduced in
JavaScript and the usage of inheritance
was also changed we'll discuss classes
and inheritance in the next video today
we are going to discuss the traditional
way of using prototypes for inheritance
so don't be stressed guys if you are not
clear with the syntax of inheritance by
the end of this video in the next video
you will understand the concept and
syntax of inheritance without any
confusion so we'll now talk about a few
things so let's start with the
programming part
so guys whenever we create an object
with a method like we can create an
object with the help of object literal
method or we can do the same with the
help of Constructor function method as
well right then we have a prototype
every time you might have noticed it we
have been through it in the past few
videos so every time we create an object
we notice that it has a prototype now
what we will do here is we'll create a
prototype so the syntax will be like so
we'll write here const we are using
const in place of variable I hope you
guys are aware of const where and let
keywords so today we are using here
const so let's say the prototype name is
employee
we'll write equals to and then we have
the body of the Prototype let's do one
thing now we'll use a method let's say
the method name is post post of the
employee
and we'll write here
function and then we have the body of
the function so let's say this function
returns a string so we'll write here
return and let's say the function
returns a
software developer and then we have
another function named as change name
and we'll write your function will pass
a parameter
and then we have the body of this method
so we'll write here this dot name
is equal to name and we are good to go
right
so what we did here is we created a
prototype of the name employee and it
has two functions one is the employees
post and the other one is to change the
name
so let's save this program and check it
in the console if it has any errors so
let's save it now and we'll go here and
check on the console
so here you can see everything is fine
so till now we created a prototype now
let's create an object as well so what
we'll do
we'll create an object here we'll write
here let's say where and let's say the
object name is even
so we'll create an object with the help
of
object Dot
create method
okay so we have to write here Dot
so we have to pass the prototype name so
we'll write here employee and then what
we'll do we'll print this on a console
so we'll write a console.log
and we'll write here even let's say so
we created an object even with the help
of object.create method let's save it
and check it on the console if we see
here we don't have anything else other
than a single prototype right we have a
single prototype here we have no method
mentioned so if we open it we have the
two methods of course we have post and
we have changed name but if we write
here let's say we are writing here even
dot name
and then value of name will be let's say
kaushal
and then we'll assign a rule as well
let's say these are the two new
properties
we'll write here even dot role and let's
say the
role of causal is
writer
fine and if we save it and check it
again on the console
now what we did is we changed the name
and Rule right so these are the two
properties we have both name as kaushal
and Rule as writer now let's see if we
can use the methods here as well
so we'll write here let's say we are
using the method even Dot
change name what we'll do here is we'll
change the name from kaushal to
something else let's say we are going to
change the name as
Ram
so if we save this now
so here you can see the name is changed
to Ram initially the name was kaushal
and when we use the change name method
now you can see here the name is changed
to Ram so this means that the methods we
defined inside the Prototype are working
right now let's say we want to create
another object here we created an object
even till now we assign some properties
to it and we changed the name and
printed it on the console now let me
tell you guys an alternate way to do so
so what we'll do is we'll copy this line
from here because the syntax of that
method also looks a bit same
so the syntax will remain the same till
here so we'll paste it here what we'll
do next is
we'll pass a few arguments here
so let's pass the arguments first then
I'll explain it to you guys so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
curly braces for arguments
and we are going to write here
it's a name and the value of name will
be we are going to write here
value
and we'll pass the value as let's say
causal 2 right
so we'll use a comma here then we'll use
role and will pass the value of rule as
well so let's say the value of rule is
programmer now
right put a comma here now I know the
syntax is a bit complicated but this is
the reason why classes were introduced
in es6 so this is the reason we will be
using classes in future but going
through this syntax will make the next
one easier for you guys so we have
created an object here with the
object.create method and we passed few
arguments here so we have name and the
value of name we want it to be causal 2
and the value of role we want it to be
programmer so if we copy this from here
or let's say if we copy these two lines
from here if we cut these two lines from
here and we'll paste it here so if you
see here we have two objects of the same
name we have where even and here also we
have variable now both these syntaxes
are doing the same thing that is
creating an object of the same name
suppose if we comment this first object
let's say we are commenting this one and
we'll also comment this line if we save
this now and if we see on our console so
here you can see we have the name as
causal 2 and Rule as programmer
so these two syntaxes are doing exactly
the same thing the only thing to notice
here is if we use this line with this
syntax if we use even dot change name
and if we save this now you can see it
is not working in this case right so if
we want to do it we have to write
some more code so what we have to do is
we have to write here
writeable
and we have to
pass the value as true
so what we are doing is we are allowing
this method to change the name from
causal 2 to ROM so if we save it now
here you can see the name is Ram now
earlier it was causal 2 and now this is
working totally fine right
so both the syntaxes are doing the same
things as we can see here the reason
behind going through this is we need the
syntax of creating objects later in this
video so I hope you guys understood it
now moving ahead let's take a look at
prototypal inheritance so what we are
going to do is we are going to comment
this code
so we are going to comment all this and
we are going to write a new one for
prototypal inheritance
let's say we have a Constructor function
so let's create a Constructor function
first so what we are going to do is we
are going to write here let's say we are
going to create the same function we'll
take the same example of employee right
so we'll write a function employee and
we'll pass the properties here let's say
we are writing a name and another one is
ID and the last properties
salary of the employer right so next up
we have the body of the Constructor so
we'll write inside here this dot name
is equal to name
then we have this dot ID equals to ID
and then we have this Dot
salary equals to salary
right
so we know this already right we'll now
add a method to the Prototype of the
employee so we'll write here we'll write
outside this Constructor will write here
employ
ee dot prototype Dot
post let's say the name of the method is
post so what we are going to do is we
are going to write your function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's say this Returns the
post of the employee what we'll do is
we'll write here return
and it will return the name plus post of
the employee right so we'll write here
this dot name
Plus
bit of space and then again
will write here
is a content creator let's say right so
we are done with the method here
as you can see what we did here is we
created a Constructor employee and added
a function that returns this string upon
calling so we haven't done anything
extra till now let's create an object
now so we'll write here let's say we are
creating an object
and what we'll do is we'll write a new
underscore employee
and we'll pass the values here so let's
say the values are causal and the ID is
four let's say this is the ID 3 4 3 2 or
whatever it is and the salary let's say
is 10 000 okay so the next thing is
we'll write here console.log
and we'll print the value of question on
a console so let's save it now and here
you can see we have all the properties
here we have IDs 3432 name is kaushal
and salary is 10 000. here if you see
inside Proto you can see here we have a
method here name is post and we have
Constructor as employee and then we have
object as well now if we call the
Prototype post with this object so what
we have to do is we have to write here
in console we'll write a causal Dot
post
and here you can see we have the output
as causal is a content creator till now
it's fine right we did small things
which we learned in the previous few
videos so let's suppose we have another
employee named Arun and let's assume is
also a content creator but he's a master
in JavaScript as well so we want to
mention it here along with all these
properties we have Name ID and salary
which we will inherit from this employee
Constructor and apart from that we'll
add another property which is the
subject or which is the language
property
so we have to create a new Constructor
here for it so what we'll do is we'll
write here
function and then we'll write the name
of this Constructor so let's say
the name is function programmer
so we'll write here name
will pass all the properties we'll write
a Name ID salary
and finally we have the language right
then we have the body of the Constructor
the first three properties will remain
the same right only subject or language
we have added languages so only language
will be added now we'll inherit these
properties from employee before the
concept of class was introduced
inheritance was based on prototypes only
so we'll see the concept of classes in
the upcoming video so
here what we are going to do is we are
going to call this employee Constructor
so we'll write here
employee Dot
call and will pass the properties which
we want to inherit so we'll write here
first this and first we have to write
this keyword and then we have to write
other properties so we'll write a Name
ID salary
what we did is we called the function
employee and asked it to provide all the
three mentioned properties to the
function programmer
will set the value of language by ursul
we'll write here
this dot language
equals to
language now if we create an object for
the Constructor program what it will do
is it will take all the properties from
the employee and language will be added
to those properties let's do it first so
we'll
create an object here we'll write here
where let's say the object name is Arun
and we'll write a new
programmer
and will pass the values let's say the
name is Arun
ID is four three two one
and salary is let's say 12 000
and finally we have to add the subject
here as well or we can say language so
let's say the language is
JavaScript
next thing we are going to do is we we
are going to print this on Console so
we'll write a console.log
and we'll print Arun
right let's save it and see here we have
all the properties available with the
provided values we have name as Arun we
have ids4321 salary is twelve thousand
and language is Javascript so this is
how we can inherit the properties in the
derived Constructor from the base
Constructor the base Constructor is the
employee and the derived is a programmer
so coming back to the console we can see
here we have all the four properties
right
three of them are inherited and the last
one was assigned by us but I don't know
if you guys noticed here that we have
the properties only of the Constructor
so we don't have any method here right
so if we see here we don't have any
method of Constructor employee because
here you can see we have a method as
post and if we see here we don't have
any method so
if we write here let's say if we write
here in a console we are writing here
let's say Arun dot post
and will
run it so here you can see it says
around dot post is not a function
right this is because the Prototype post
is not assigned to the Constructor
programmer for that we have to write
some extra code we have to write here
so we have to write here
programmer dot prototype equals to
object Dot
create and we have to mention the
employee prototype
so we'll write here employee Dot
prototype right so save it now and here
you can see now if you go to underscore
underscore Proto we have post as a
method here
so if we write here
Arun dot post now
so here you can see it says Arun is a
content creator so we have to provide
the prototypes manually as well
let me show you guys one more thing now
see here it is not showing the
Constructor if we click here on the
Proto we don't have any Constructor here
named as programmer
so we have to set the Constructor as
well we have to set it manually and to
set the Constructor manually we have to
write here after this line we have to
write here programmer dot prototype
Dot
Constructor
equals to programmer if we save this
program now and if we go back to our
console and if we check here here you
can see we have a Constructor named as
programmer now
so you guys might be thinking that we
have to work a lot for all this
inheritance right the fact is we
actually had to do it before es6 was
introduced now if you want to do the
same with the help of classes the syntax
will be so easy
class is nothing but a template used for
creating objects in JavaScript just like
the Constructor function we can also use
classes for creating object in
JavaScript we can include properties and
behaviors in our class creating a class
is a pretty easy job to do the syntax is
somewhat the same as that of a
Constructor function so let's move on to
the programming part if you guys are
coming from any other object oriented
programming language like we have C plus
plus Java PHP and many more object
oriented programming language right so
you may have an idea about classes the
Syntax for classes in JavaScript is also
not so different from other languages
don't worry if you are going through
classes for the first time well have a
look at classes so let's move on to the
syntax
and to declare a class we use the class
keyword followed by the name of the
class and the body of the class so we'll
write a class so this is the keyword we
use for the Declaration of a class then
we have the name of the class so let's
say we have the name as student here and
then we use curly braces for the body of
the class so this is an empty class
named as student we know that